en le cas des fonctionnaires enseignants
puisqu'il y avait une revalorisation qui
étaient inscrits
c'est quelqu'un qui éternue derrière moi
barco oui donc les fonctionnaires
avaient un problème dans le cadre de
leur rémunération ce qu'on a très vite
compris qu'ils auraient une baisse de
leur rémunération
vous avez du fait des remarques du
conseil d'état vous avez inscrit un
article spécifique les enseignants sont
à l'article 1 bis ça montre bien qu'il y
avait un problème de constitutionnalité
dans votre dans votre article et
liminaire ensuite on a un problème par
rapport aux fonctionnaires territoriaux
vous savez que 75 % des fonctionnaires
territoriaux ou qu'il s'agisse des
communes des départements ou des régions
sont des fonctionnaires de catégorie c
qui ne bénéficie pas de prime qui
commence avec des niveaux de revenus
relativement bas la retraite calculée
sur les six derniers mois de leur
rémunération et est ce qu'on appelait le
coup de chapeau
c'était pas une retraite chapeau c'était
le coup de chapeau le fait que vous
preniez en compte la totalité de leur
carrière va forcément faire chuter leurs
perspectives de retraite ça serait une
retraite réduite pour tous ces
fonctionnaires de catégorie c alors
monsieur le ministre
est ce que vous avez prévu de pouvoir
compenser les collectivités qui
accepteront l'idée d'augmenter ses
fonctionnaires là pour leur donner un
niveau de retraite décent et comment on
articule si les collectivités voulait le
faire d'elle-même comment on articule
cette disposition avec celles qui ont
signé le pacte de cahors puisque vous
les à les obliger à ne pas augmenter
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement
globalement donc il ya cet aspect qui
est un peu contradictoire
pour toutes ces raisons ces techniques
mais en même temps c'est une réalité de
toutes les collectivités territoriales
pour toutes ces raisons nous supprimons
donc proposant la suppression de
l'article 6
merci
monsieur juanico vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président et pour
poursuivre effectivement les propos de
marie christine dalloz
bien évidemment il ya le pour les
fonctionnaires le point d'interrogation
majeur qui concerne les enseignants je
ne reviens pas à ce stade nous avons eu
l'occasion de développer amplement il ya
quelques jours
mais effectivement une question qui se
pose immédiatement après c'est le sort
réservé aux fonctionnaires de la
fonction publique territoriale et de la
fonction publique hospitalière qui
touchent peu de primes et qui sont dans
des conditions relativement similaires à
ceux de l'éducation nationale mais le
système de retraite par points on le
sait est particulièrement défavorable
aux fonctionnaires du fait de la prise
en compte de la rémunération sur
l'ensemble de la carrière d'une part et
du fait de la prise de la place prise
par les primes dans la rémunération
totale de ceux-ci d'autres pas cette
réforme aurait par ailleurs à coût
exorbitant pour la caisse universel de
retraite
je vous renvoie au tableau figurant à la
page 143 de l'excellente étude d'impact
et qui est extrêmement révélateur
aujourd'hui les cotisations versées par
l'état pour la fonction publique d'état
s'établissent à 38 7 milliards d'euros
sur la part traitement et à 299
milliards millions d'euros pour là part
prime à base salariale égalé avec les
nouveaux taux de cotisation la part
traitement ne représentent plus que 8 7
milliards d'euros et la part prime passe
à 1 milliard d'euros
ainsi à compter du passage en rythme de
croisière de la réforme en 2042
les cotisations de l'état seront
inférieures de 29,3 milliards d'euros à
ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui à masse
salariale égales pour l'ensemble des
fonctions publiques on atteint donc une
baisse de cotisations de 42,8 milliards
d'euros par an en 2042 vous nous dites
pas aujourd'hui comment cette perte de
ressources financières sera
effectivement compenser
merci l'art ne poursuivant les
amendements de suppression semer année
vous avez la parole pour le 6108
merci monsieur président cet article
intègre les fonctionnaires magistrats et
militaires dans ce système prétendu
universel des retraites
le système actuel de retraites des
fonctionnaires répondent à la
spécificité de leur métier et à la place
particulière qui remplace et qui
remplissent et dans l'organisation de
notre société
ils accomplissent une mission de service
public qui mérite d'être justement
récompensés et celle inverse qui se
produira avec votre réforme
les fonctionnaires de catégorie b et c
en particulier seront lourdement touché
par un calcul sur la totalité de la
carrière au lieu des six derniers mois
le nouveau régime entraînera
mécaniquement une baisse des pensions de
ceux qui ont passé une partie ou toute
leur carrière au service de l'état et
donc des français si nous prenons le cas
des militaires en particulier je
souhaite vous rappelez l'avis
défavorable du conseil supérieur de la
fonction militaire sur ce projet de loi
et les remarques adressées au
gouvernement qui pointe une baisse des
pensions pouvant atteindre 60 % les
moins gradés
les militaires du rang étant les plus
touchés pourtant à plusieurs reprises le
président macron a assuré qu'il
veillerait à ce que la singularité du
métier militaire soit prise en compte
dans le projet de réforme des retraites
il a déclaré il n'y a donc pas lieu de
transiger avec l'exigence de
disponibilité en tout temps et en tout
lieu
il faut sans cesse rappeler que le
service des armes et imprévisible risque
est dangereux qu'ils impliquent esprit
de sacrifice pouvant aller jusqu'au
sacrifice suprême
et il avait raison jean paul delevoye
alors haut commissaire à la réforme des
retraites avait affirmé pour sa part que
le système universel maintiendrait les
particularités objectivement justifiée
par les missions assignées aux
militaires alors je vous pose la
question mes chers collègues
cette réforme apporte apporte-t-elle une
reconnaissance quelconque envers ceux
qui risquent leur vie pour nous pour
vous je remercie
merci mes jeunes collègues en la parole
de l'un pour le 21 1925
kim olympia tous avaient la parole d'un
pardonnez moi vous étiez monsieur matin
était juste avant vous avez la parole
mais il était tout en bas remet sur
votre teint merci monsieur le président
oui je tenais à moi aussi sur cet
amendement a rappelé l'inquiétude des
élus locaux qui sont de très gros
employeur d'agents publics bien entendu
et qui se trouve dans une situation où
d'une part ils ne seront pas quelle va
être représentée la charge des
cotisations patronales pour les agents
territoriaux et d'autre part ces mêmes
agents territoriaux sont très souvent
peu primés ou pas primé du tout
notamment dans les quatre dans la
catégorie c qui représentent 76% des
effectifs globaux et donc par conséquent
le calcul de la retraite ne pourra pas
faire avec une augmentation pure par
intégration des primes puisqu'il n'y a
pas de prime
je pense qu'il serait assez utile de
revoir le calcul dans ces cas là pour
qu' on puisse avoir un effet comparable
si malheureusement votre retraite
finissait par s'appliquer
merci merci monsieur le président nous
souhaitons effectivement supprimer cet
article 6 qui du fait de supprimer le
calcul de la pension retraite par an
prenant en compte les six derniers mois
va faire perdre beaucoup d'argent aux
fonctionnaires alors toutes les
catégories des fonctionnaires je pense
aussi aux fonctionnaires de l'assemblée
nationale tout à l'heure hommage à leur
a été rendu mais c'est vrai qu'on y
pense que très rarement mais sans tous
ces fonctionnaires de l'assemblée
nationale ne serions bien perdu dans les
travées de cet hémicycle
vous connaissez mes positions donc si
jamais nous n'arrivons pas à faire
supprimer cet article si vous allez
m'entendre très régulièrement parler du
personnel
comment hospitalier et je sais que
monsieur le président le furent m'en
voudra pas mais après il ya quelques
jours je ne sais plus on avait parlé de
l'aïs sage qui devenait deux soignantes
et infirmières puis cadres sup et une
réponse avait été fait en disant que
c'était des cas rares sachez monsieur le
ministre que ce n'est pas un cas rare
parce que chez nous les professionnels
de la santé
ces cadres sup on les appelle les
meilleurs parce que justement ils sont
passés par tous les
les postes donc non ce ne sont pas des
cas rares etc ces personnes ce sont ces
personnes là qui vont perdre le plus
avec cet article 6 donc c'est pourquoi
nous nous vous demandons de supprimer
cet article 6 parce que vous allez faire
perdre beaucoup trop d'argent à tous ses
fonctionnaires en leur retirant ce pot
calcul des pensions de retraites sur les
six derniers mois
d'où cet amendement merci le 27 1348
monsieur mac est il est défendu défendu
[Musique]
le 31000 0,30 la ville
merci monsieur monsieur le président
donc cet article prévoit que le système
universel soit disant universel de
retraite par points s'applique aux
agents de la fonction publique et aux
magistrats
à la fin du calcul de la retraite sur la
base des six derniers mois pour les cinq
millions de fonctionnaires constituent
un très très grave recul
cela va conduire à une baisse mécanique
des pensions que l'intégration des
primes ne suffira pas à compenser
notamment pour les enseignants mais pas
seulement un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales se sont déjà
fortement mobilisés sur ce sujet l'une
d'entre elle parlait d'un cataclysme
plus de lien réel direct sérieux avec le
salaire plus de continuité plus de
salaire continué avec un taux de
remplacement garantie pour les agents de
la fonction publique
il s'agit et d'un affaiblissement
considérable de leurs droits horizon
déjà subi une dégradation continue
quasiment de la valeur du point en tout
cas significatif depuis des années
maintenant qui a engendré une perte
considérable
pouvoir d'achat qui se traduit
naturellement pour chacune et chacun à
leur arrivée à l'âge de la retraite au
moment de liquider leur pension
tout cela est la démonstration que votre
projet ne tient pas compte du réel
il ne tient pas compte de la réalité
c'est une mécanique qui a été construite
comme une sorte d'algorithmes sur le
papier et qui a bien du mal à entrer
réellement en résonance avec la vie en
tout cas quand elle le fait elle produit
des dégâts considérables
c'est la marque de l'inadaptation de
votre projet aux situations diverses que
connaissent les femmes et les hommes de
notre pays s'il y avait des modes de
calcul différent c'est parce qu'il y
avait des parcours différents parce
qu'il y avait des structures de carrière
différente parce qu'il y avait des
structures de rémunérations différentes
et votre projet n'en tient aucun compte
et en tout cas quand il le fait parce
que vous êtes amené à un certain nombre
de corrections et bien il fait la
démonstration de son incapacité en
réalité à faire fonctionner correctement
un système qui garantisse le droit à la
retraite
je crois que avec cet article nous
touchons du doigt véritablement le
cataclysme en effet que va provoquer
votre réforme
madame ménard à la parole merci monsieur
le président cet article 6 vise
l'assurance vieillesse des
fonctionnaires des magistrats et des
militaires on a parlé un peu des deux
premiers je voulais revenir sur les
militaires la réforme des retraites en
cours de discussion va leur porter
préjudice malheureusement elle vise à
aligner le statut des militaires sur
l'ensemble des autres statuts notamment
en encourageant les militaires à
travailler plus longtemps
or cela est tout à fait contraire avec
le modèle d'une armée jeunes et une
logique de flux optimal ainsi qu'au
principe du temps de service
l'avis du conseil supérieur de la
fonction militaire n'est d'ailleurs pas
favorable à ce projet de loi et c'est
pourquoi je demande la suppression de
l'article si je remercie monsieur le
président merci
alors donc je crois que l'ensemble des
amendements a pu être présenté monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président bonsoir à
toutes et à tous nous arrivons avec cet
article 6 sur la filiation des
fonctionnaires des magistrats et des
militaires aussi au système universel et
c'est peut-être la filiation qui est
l'incarnation la plus tangible au fond
de l'universalité de ce système tant
cette affiliation transcende la
distinction entre secteur public et
secteur et secteur privé
cette intégration mettre un fin un
ensemble de règles dérogatoires trop
souvent mal comprise aujourd'hui par nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens et
s'accompagnera bien évidemment de
dispositions spécifiques pour certains
métiers notamment les métiers régalien
particulièrement dangereux
ces dispositions spécifiques seront
également discutés dans les chapitres
suivants du projet de loi
cet article ci se limitant à la
définition du champ d'application du
régime des fonctionnaires tout en
franchissant l'obstacle symbolique d'une
insertion dans le code de la sécurité
sociale aussi ce sera un avis
défavorable cependant sur trois points
que j'ai entendues soit parmi les
différents points soulevés peut-être
d'abord sur la participation de l'état
redire ce qui a été expliqué par le
ministre notamment et les rapporteurs
sur le fait que la contribution de
l'état de 38 milliards d'euros je crois
que nos collègues
chers collègues ironico vous citer
twitter 42,6 c'est avec les
collectivités territoriales
donc la contribution de 30 milliards de
de l'etat sera bien entendu maintenues
dans le futur système universel et
d'ailleurs c'est précise à la page 143
de l'étude d'impact concernant les
fonctionnaires
2 les fonctionnaires parlementaires je
tiens à vous prévenir tout de suite mais
vous l'aviez sûrement vu que j'ai déposé
plusieurs amendements afin d'intégrer
les fonctionnaires de nos assemblées au
futur système universel enfin concernant
la prise en compte de le changement de
calcul de la retraite
en passant des six derniers mois à la
prise en compte de l'ensemble de la
carrière bien entendu ça entraînera une
prise en compte des des primes qui au
passage d'ailleurs était une
revendication à ses anciennes des
fonctionnaires ce qui entraînera une
hausse de cotisation une hausse de
cotisations qui va s'étaler sur sur près
d'une dune d'une vingtaine d'années
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président j'ai un avis
défavorable à la suppression de cet
article
monsieur le rapporteur s'est exprimé
pour rappeler à la fois combien il était
important que les fonctionnaires
puissent être même régime que l'ensemble
des autres actifs mais aussi en donnant
des précisions sur la façon dont se
ferait à la fois les transitions sur les
cotisations que je confirme mais
également sur la nécessité qu'il y aura
à exercer des transitions longue et
douce notamment pour permettre à tous
ceux qui verront l'intégration des
primes dans le calcul des cotisations
vieillesse les voir progresser lentement
vers le taux de cotisations qu'ils
auront à supporter au niveau salarial
la différence entre le 28 12 et le taux
de cotisation sera compensée
progressivement par l'état puis une
prise en charge à hauteur de 0,25 point
par an par les salariés
les collaborateurs fonctionnaires vous
dire quand même sur le point la question
madame dalloz qui
ils s'inquiétaient d'une baisse de la
rémunération des fonctionnaires
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire les
catégories c je crois qu'on en avait
parlé à plusieurs reprises notamment
pour les atsem vous savez ce sont
essentiellement des du coup les
fonctionnaires territoriaux qui ont des
carrières qui sont relativement plate et
qui ont peu de changements d'échelon
d'ailleurs voilà et donc du coup ils ont
pas de prime et le la mécanique du
système de retraites va les avantages et
particulièrement puisque c'est très
redistributive vers notamment les
carrières qui sont relativement linéaire
et les niveaux de rémunérations qui sont
relativement faibles
donc j'avais expliqué déjà il ya
quelques jours mais je leur fais bien
volontiers pour rappeler que le système
de retraite universel par répartition et
par point leur sera favorable
et c'est d'ailleurs en cela que nous
avions eu un débat il ya quelques jours
puisque il avait été souligné je crois
sur ces bandes ailleurs qu' il y avait
une différence de regard porté sur la
retraite des enseignants et ceux des
fonctionnaires territoriaux donc j'avais
rappelé à l'époque les fonctionnaires
territoriaux avait un niveau de prix
moyen de 22 % c'est-à-dire quasiment le
même niveau de prix moyen que celui qui
existe dans l'ensemble de la fonction
publique mais que pour les carrières
plates linéaire et notamment les
catégories c cela ne serait pas une
difficulté puisqu'il serait avantagé par
le système de redistribution qu'il y a à
l'intérieur du système universel de
retraite par répartition et par points
tout simplement parce que les carrières
plus la carrière à une progression
importante plus le détail de primes
devient significatif donc là ce ne sera
pas le cas pour les catégories c'est que
vous avez évoquées voilà pourquoi j'ai
donné un avis défavorable mais le
président s'il a plusieurs orateurs
souhaité exprimer monsieur letchimy et
la parole monsieur very se prépare oui
monsieur le ministre
l'observation de madame dalloz je pense
doit être prise très au sérieux parce
que le nombre de fonctionnaires
notamment des collectivités locales de
catégorie c c'est près de
1 millions 5,1 millions 6 ses 76 %
environ de la masse des fonctionnaires
catégorie c je vois pas tellement com
comment en calculant la requête sur
l'ensemble la carrière avec une carrière
ascendante à la fin pourrait permettre
d'avoir le même type de retraite
d'ailleurs la mef s'est ému de cette
situation et notre intervention c'est
pour attirer votre attention à la
prudence je voudrais aussi m'exprimer
sur la question des primes notamment la
prime de vie chère en outre-mer nous
avons un débat nous avons une discussion
j'ai cru comprendre lors de la
commission spéciale que ce qui est très
attentif à l'évolution de cette affaire
il y a un rapport à la délégation
d'outre-mer que j'ai signé qui sera le
cadre d'une négociation et d'un débat je
suis personnellement nous sommes très
nombreux à être personnellement
favorable à l'intégration de la prime de
40% dans le calcul des pensions
la seule chose ça va entraîner comme
conséquences à la fois une prise en
compte des cotisations quand il s'agit
de l'état pour les enseignants même si
encore la sphère des primes pour les
enseignants qui risque de baisser leurs
patients il ya aussi les collectivités
locales qui devront assumer ses
conséquences là vous avez répondu que la
baisse des cotisations permettra à ces
collectivités de tout compenser mais il
ya aussi un élément très important c'est
que quand vous allez demander à la fois
aux enseignants et aux agents de cotiser
sur la prime de 40% ça va diminuer le
revenu pendant au moins une quinzaine
d'années dans quelles sont les mesures
que vous comptez prendre je considère
que là il ya un enjeu fondamental pour
l'ensemble de l'outre-mer
merci merci sur cet article 6 qui
intègre dans le système universel les
fonctionnaires les militaires et
magistrats c'est faut-il le dire un
sujet majeur depuis plusieurs années
depuis plusieurs réformes depuis 2003 en
particulier les paramètres de calcul et
de revalorisation des pensions de base
des fonctionnaires d'état se rapprochent
de ceux des services privés du secteur
privé en commission spéciale nous avons
eu ces discussions monsieur le ministre
j'ai
ne t en commission spéciale que 50 % des
fonctionnaires d'état seraient concernés
par le nouveau système c'est à dire que
globalement eu un fonctionnaire sur deux
pourrait être intégré dans le système
universel de façon progressive
a vous de me dire si cela est exact pas
est-ce que ça va concerner l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires ou pas et à l'appui
de cette question je vous invite à lire
sur l'amendement déposé par notre
collègue marie christine dalloz
vous savez nous nous sommes favorables
nous sommes favorables à continuer le
fil du temps le fil de l'histoire par
rapport à cet alignement public privé
par rapport à cette convergence est
faut-il reconnaître que dans ce projet
de loi vous offrez vous offrez une voie
permettant de tracer un chemin
le sujet c'est effectivement les
modalités l'atterrissage la sauvegarde
des situations des fonctionnaires pour
que au final chacun puisse être gagnant
les agents bien sûr leur employeur est
la nation dans sa globalité par rapport
à l'importance que l'on peut accorder à
l'intérêt général et aux services
publics
on conçoit bien clair votre réforme
n'intègre que le système de retraite et
pas les autres services sociaux j'aurai
donc une question monsieur ministre par
rapport me semble-t-il à une dérogation
une dérogation qui devrait concerner les
fonctionnaires territoriaux et les
fonctionnaires hospitaliers en emplois
permanents à titre non complet ou pour
les autres fonctionnaires qui ne sont
pas affiliés à la cnra cl c'est à dire
ce qui reste affilié pour le régime
général de retraite de base et à lire à
l'ircantec pour la retraite
complémentaire
j'ai cru comprendre que vous autorisiez
un glissement un passage progressif à
mode de transition sur une période qui
me paraît assez long à savoir 2039
est-ce vrai ou pas cela me paraît long
cela me paraît trop confus cela ne
paraît pas aller dans la convergence que
nous souhaitons un dernier match
opposant parce que le sujet a été ouvert
sur la situation des fonctionnaires de
cette assemblée
j'ai été ouvert par monsieur rapporteur
et un amendement va nova nova nous va
nous contraindre à nous prononcer
la question est de l'intégration ou pas
dans le système universel il va de soi
que les fonctionnaires que nous côtoyer
au quotidien ont une charge de travail
excessivement importante lourde et
importante à notre démocratie
et je voudrais les remercier
la question se pose de la séparation des
pouvoirs de ce qui constitue un état de
droit dessus depuis deux sites qui doit
coûte que coûte tenir l'indépendance du
législatif qu'il ne doit admettre aucune
soumission aucune dépendance y compris
dans le statut et le statut en portent
nécessairement la question de la
retraite
ça mérite d'être posée parce que dès
lors qu'on dépend d'un statut on perd de
sa liberté
on perde de son indépendance et la
question doit être posée peut-être que
sous couvert d'un amendement technique
le sujet est beaucoup plus profond que
cela merci monsieur perry a demandé la
parole
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
intervenir sur cette cet article où ça
va pas vous étonner je ne suis pas
favorable à ça à sa suppression
comme beaucoup d'entre vous ici j'ai été
élu local
et puis c'est mon métier d'être
directeur de collectivités territoriales
et ce système de statut particulier
avait quand même trois problèmes qui
vont disparaître et qui me paraît
important de mettre en avant parce que
nous ne l'avons pas fait le premier
c'est que lorsque vous rendriez trop
tard dans la fonction publique on vous
conseiller de refuser la titularisation
parce que racheter vos points ou
reprendre vos points ce n'était pas
intéressant pour votre retraite et donc
on a maintenu comme ça déjà su statut
précaire uniquement parce que le fait de
rentrer dans le statut dans le régime
des fonctionnaires n'était pas
intéressant pour eux avec notre régime
on le supprime le deuxième élément le
deuxième élément c'est qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de personnes qui pouvait
racheter leur carrière antérieure
parce qu'ils avaient les moyens de
racheter ces points ceux qui n'avaient
pas les moyens et bien été pénalisés
dans leur retraite et donc avec ce
système là aussi nous allons supprimer
et donc tout le monde sera sur un même
pied d'égalité
on aura passé points à racheter puisque
tout sera lissé et donc nous aurons une
égalité y compris entre ceux qui ont les
moyens de racheter et ceux qui n'auront
pas les moyens de racheter et donc ils
ne seront pas pénalisés pour leur
retraite et le troisième point et là
j'en appelle à tous ceux qui ont vu de
l'expérience dans la gestion des
collectivités territoriales on sait très
bien que dans la gestion notamment des
catégories c à la fin on donnait le
dernier échelon pour les six mois en
leur disant pour les plus ambitieux on
appelait ça le chevron on leur disait tu
auras le chevron et en fait on leur
donnait au dernier moment avant de
partir à la retraite
ce petit bonus pour qu'ils en profitent
au moment de leur retraite et donc ça
générer une gestion des carrières de
catégorie c qui n'était pas dynamique on
les maintenaient toute leur carrière sur
des échelons plutôt bas et au dernier
moment on leur donnait ce chevron alors
ça te fera une meilleure retraite ce
système là va permettre d'avoir une
vraie carrière dynamique
une carrière qui sont en phase avec
l'engagement des agents et non pas cette
récompense qu'au dernier au dernier
moment pour valoriser la retraite et la
faire payer par un régime spécial
je vous remercie mais quel dédain à la
parole merci monsieur le président chers
collègues
les fonctionnaires de notre pays ont
déjà des traitements des rémunérations
qui sont faibles et bien plus faible que
dans les autres pays de l'osce et de
nous avons commencé à en discuter avant
la pause tout à l'heure clairement le
calcul sur les six derniers mois
permettait d' amortir cela et de leur
assurer un niveau de pension qui soit le
meilleur possible compte tenu du fait
que les évolutions de carrière
le passage des échelons assuré le fait
que les six derniers mois correspondent
par définition à la meilleure période de
leur carrière en termes de rémunération
en supprimant le calcul sur la base des
six derniers mois
vous assurez aux fonctionnaires le fait
d'avoir des pensions plus faibles et ils
seront exactement de la même manière que
le seront ceux du privé avec la
suppression du calcul sur la base des 25
meilleures années assurément perdant sur
le niveau des pensions
à moins d'une revalorisation absolument
incroyable et a priori à laquelle
voulait pas près de leur traitement et
de leur rémunération
alors dites-nous précisément peut-être
monsieur le ministre quel engagement
vous pourriez prendre parce que quand on
entend par exemple ministre blanc caire
nous parlait des enseignants on voit que
les revalorisations qui seront promises
ne sont même pas en capacité d'amortir
le choc de simplement l'inflation sur
les effets de salaires des enseignants
alors pouvez vous oui ou non vous
engager à ce que ce projet de loi ne
s'applique pas aux fonctionnaires tant
que leurs revenus et leurs rémunérations
ne seront pas à une hauteur suffisante
qui permettra d'amortir le choc que va
provoquer la suppression de ce calcul
sur les six derniers mois
c'est extrêmement important parce que
oui de fait c'est par ce type de calcul
modifié que vous allez faire
à vis des gens par le calcul de leur
pension la variable d'ajustement de l'
équilibre financier que vous rechercher
à tout prix mais que vous le faite que
sur le dos des seuls actifs sans jamais
vouloir récupérer une part de la
richesse produite qui va dans les poches
de tous les autres qui en ont beaucoup
profité ces dernières années nous avons
les moyens nous le répéterons autant
qu'il le faudra de financer un système
de retraite qui permettent de partir dès
60 ans avec un bon niveau de pension
c'est valable tant pour les
fonctionnaires que pour les salariés du
privé c'est pas cher monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure les agriculteurs
on nous dit c'est compliqué on n'y
comprend rien et on fait pas confiance
maintenant les fonctionnaires ils nous
écrivent tous ils nous disent c'est
compliqué on n'y comprend rien on ne
fait pas confiance
les professions indépendantes libéral
vont nous dire nous disent mais on n'y
comprend rien c'est compliqué on fait
pas confiance
j'ai fait 34 cérémonie de voeux dans mon
département au mois de janvier entre 80
et 150 personnes en moyenne
toute la base me disait on n'y comprend
rien on fait pas confiance
suis je suis venue d'un département
rural c'est moi même j'y comprends rien
non plus et j'ai terminé par les voeux
au conseil économique social et
environnemental présidents des grandes
fédérations professionnelles les autres
m'ont dit on n'y comprend rien on fait
pas confiance je vais vous poser une
question monsieur le ministre a parlé
quelques-uns ici dans cet hémicycle qui
semble avoir compris quelque chose qui
comprend réellement quelque chose à
votre réforme est ce qui n'est pas le
temps est ce qu'on n'a pas le temps
quand même nous donner un petit peu de
temps pour réfléchir et remettre tout à
plat
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
d'abord répondre à mon collègue les
maires des communes ne font pas ce
qu'ils veulent avec les employés
communaux y compris dans il ya des
grilles indiciaires
il ya des échelons et tout ça est bien
encadré dans la fonction publique etc le
ministère de la fonction publique qui
règlent ça avec l'ensemble des syndicats
j'ai jamais vu un maire peut-être chasse
pas chez vous mais ça m'étonnerait que
le maire puisse faire ça il ya des codes
ya des règles et les mères est ce que
doivent appliquer cela alors bon je
regrette monsieur mais vous dites
n'importe quoi je regrette de vous le
dire mais vous dites n'importe quoi et
vous mettez en cause vous mettez en
cause les maires les responsabilités les
maires vous mettez en cause les maires
s'il vous plaît mais sa collègue on
s'écoute on s'écoute
allez on s'écoute et deuxièmement
heureusement ce que je voudrais
souligner c'est que à travers cet
article 6
je suis pour la suppression parce que la
filiation c'est la filiation du public
et du privé et ça veut dire que c'est
toute la fonction publique c'est tout le
service public vous vous remettez en
cause c'est tout ce qu'on veut la police
et quand vous avez les les pompiers qui
viennent des positions dans ces braves
les pompiers etc
quand il ya eu des fdf qui doivent
intervenir gaasch a eu des tempêtes ces
travaux edf gdf et maintenant vous dites
quand j'ai terminé parce que c'est plus
grave que ça c'est c'est tout le statut
c'est tout la fonction du service public
le service qui est rendu aux citoyens
c'est ça que vous remettez en cause et
donc comme ça on peut pas l'accepter tel
que vous le présenter c'est pour ça que
nous nous sommes pour sa suppression
merci merci monsieur le président oui
cet article concerne les fonctionnaires
les catégories c est effectivement les
enseignants et toute notre vie on nous a
dit oui mais tu as les vacances donc te
plains pas et puis ensuite on nous a dit
oui mettent à la retraite donc te plains
pas et clairement ce qu'on appelle
encore les dinosaures instit ne gagne
rien de toute leur vie de toute leur
carrière n'ont aucune prime
aucune heure sup vraiment rien de
possible même par rapport
aux profs du secondaire qui quand ils en
prof principale où on peuvent avoir un
peu d'argent en plus en tout cas pour
les profs d'école c'est un vrai souci
un vrai souci alors j'entends bien qu'il
ya une loi de programmation 10 milliards
c'est du jamais vu
j'entends aussi que le conseil d'état
n'a pas manqué de sanctionner dans son
avis comme une injonction au
gouvernement et de déposer un projet de
loi qui serait ainsi contraire à la
constitution
donc je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre quelle certitude pouvons-nous
avoir qu'un futur gouvernement entérine
ou appliquent une loi de programmation à
la base non constitutionnelle je vous
remercie
merci ma chère collègue donc chacun des
groupes qui souhaitait a pu s'exprimer
en a je veux dire merci monsieur le
président moi je voudrais interrogé des
choses qu'on vient d'entendre et kimi
qui me pose problème
on parle du rôle redistributif des
retraites le rôle redistributif des
retraites
que ce soit pour la pénibilité pendant
la vie que ce soit pour la pauvreté
pendant la vie le rôle redistributif des
retraites c'est pas un correctif
retarder des problèmes qu'on a eus
pendant la vie c'est pendant la carrière
qu'il faut se battre et prévenir la
pénibilité
c'est pendant la carrière qu'il faut
aller chercher la précarité et la
distrait le rôle redistributif des
retraites c'est de réduire les autres
traitent et de monter les petites
retraites
c'est donc complètement contradictoire
de dire que on veut un rôle
redistributif des retraites et de
bricoler des systèmes qui permettent
d'avoir des grosses retraites à des gens
qui ont été mal payée toute leur vie
c'est contradictoire de dire qu'on veut
l'un rhodia 1re distributif des
retraites alors qu'on tolère on continue
à tolérer les très hautes retraite que
vous refusez de plafonner c'est
contradictoire de dire qu'on veut un
rôle redistributif des retraites
quand on profite des retraites pour
corriger les choses qu'on n'a pas eu le
courage de corriger pendant la carrière
merci car chacun a pu regagner sa place
d'un vote électronique
donc nous avons tous les amendements de
suppression avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement
l'ensemble des amendements de
suppression qui commence par les 492
monsieur de le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
votre gâteau pour exprimer 91 majorité
46 pour 31 contre 60
l'amendement n'est donc pas adoptée 25
1161 monsieur jouannic comme tu vas
l'eau aux yeux
monsieur vélo vélo oui merci monsieur le
président bon je joue je refais un bond
de ma dernière intervention à celle là
puisque j'avais dit au ministre avait
fait la promesse que j'essaierai de lui
apporter la démonstration que la
référence à laquelle il m'avait envoyé
qui étaient les études d'impact
correspondait aux études de aux
hypothèses du cor sur l'augmentation de
la part des primes de 0,23 point bas en
50 ans pour les fonctionnaires alors je
suis allé voir j'ai cherché d'abord il a
fallu que je trouve qu'elle rapport du
cor il s'agissait donc je pense que
c'est celui de juin 2019 et dans lequel
on peut lire que pour l'essentiel les
projections sont établies sur la base
d'une stabilité de la part des primes
que depuis 2010 est il ya une variante
globale qui a été introduite et qui
prévoit une évolution de la part des
primes prolongeant une tendance celle
des 25 meilleures années
et puis s'agissant des enseignants le
rapport souligne que la hausse est plus
limitée chez les enseignants dont la
part des primes est faible et puis on
note également que la hausse des primes
marque le pas depuis 2011 donc soutenir
que l'hypothèse qui est retenue par le
par le parent autre étude d'impact et
qui permet en réalité de comparer très
favorablement votre réforme avec une des
projections qui sont absolument
absurde et bien c'est très malhonnête de
considérer qu'elles reprennent les
hypothèses du cor
merci alors sur cet amendement monsieur
de rapporte défavorable chez ministre si
le client a un mot pour répondre au
député boris jaloux de lui confirmer que
le scénario prime du cor prévoit bien
une progression de 0,23 que donc nous en
rediscuterons si le voeu de façon plus
attentive tous les deux j'avais proposé
de le faire on vous écoutant je prenais
un peu de temps pour reprendre le dock
mais regardons ça ensemble dans ce cadre
nous nous avons pris les éléments du
corps et je pense qu'on trouvera
ensemble explication à cette à cette
divergence pas inquiet en la matière à
soupe de questions qui ont été posées
le député viry vous inquiet inquiétiez
des fonctionnaires de cette assemblée
vous rappeler la vie peut-être du
conseil d'état sur la page 38 de son
avis qui indiquait que tous cas
effectivement était constitutionnelle
que d'intégrer les fonctionnalités
assemblée dans le système universel et
qu'il était de la compétence du bureau
des assemblées sur les modalités de
transition et la mise en oeuvre monsieur
viry toujours capter en veine de poser
des questions tout à l'heure
s'inquiétait aussi des fonctionnaires au
temps non complet à 25 heures par
semaine
aujourd'hui sont d'ailleurs dans le
régime des salariés à l'ircantec
ils seront toujours soumis au régime des
salariés demain dans le cadre du système
universel sur les questions qui avaient
été posés tout à l'heure ce que j'ai
répondu de façon assez global macro
économique on peut retourner si vous
voulez sur les fonctionnaires catégorie
c sur les cas types qui sont page 208
pages de sang neuf pour retrouver
d'étude d'impact pour retrouver et
répondre aux questions telles que rossi
et qui venait d'ailleurs aussi des bancs
de la gauche sur quid de du traitement
de la retraite sur la carrière complète
par rapport aux six derniers mois pour
trouver ou de remplacements opérés qui
sont très proches les uns les autres et
que effectivement il n'y a pas lieu
d'imaginer deux grands cataclysmes comme
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure voilà les
avis défavorables monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président est ce qu
merci monsieur le président on est le 27
février les 21h45
ça fait onze jours qu'on est ensemble il
reste 30 1785 amendements à examiner
j'ai entendu avant la pause une
assertion qui m'a surpris puis comme
monsieur quatre mains cela à nouveau
affirmé en début de séance ce soir j'ai
décidé d'y répondre
monsieur 4,9 vous connaissez les études
de l' ocde comme moi la réalité c'est
que dans l'ensemble les fonctionnaires
français sont plutôt bien rémunérés et
pour certains même très bien rémunéré
oui par rapport aux autres grands pays
à deux exceptions très importante
la première exception et je doute que
monsieur 4 nages c'est celle qu'il a en
tête c'est les très hauts dirigeants de
la fonction publique qui sont nettement
moins rémunérés en france qu'ailleurs
dans le monde et la deuxième et nous en
occupons de très près dans ce projet de
loi ce sont les enseignants
effectivement les enseignants français
sont nettement moins payés que les
enseignants à peu près partout dans le
monde c'est un véritable scandale
je demande aux majorité précédente de
faire face à leurs responsabilités quand
sa tête situation en ce qui nous
concerne nous la corrigeons et puis un
autre point très important c'est les
primes parce qu'effectivement une des
inégalités criantes des fonctionnaires
face à la retraite c'est que les prix ne
sont pas intégrés et celle là aussi nous
y mettons fin
et puis troisième point ça a été dit un
peu par monsieur perea
vous connaissez tous 112 des
instituteurs des professeurs qui à 50 55
ans en ont marre sont épuisés aimerait
bien faire autre chose et combien de
fois on a entendu en tout cas combien de
fois j'ai entendu
maintenant je rêve je suis à cinq ans de
la retraite je suis à sept ans de la
retraite
je vais pas partir à 7 ans de la
retraite la réalité c'est que dans ce
système de points universel on aura
revaloriser leur rémunération et ceux
qui en auront marre à 50 55 ans pourront
aller faire autre chose préserver leurs
droits à la retraite
les compléter et avoir une retraite
correcte comme toutes les françaises et
les français y ont droit
je vous remercie
merci monsieur des coeurs à la parole
monsieur del ben oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président je viens
d'entendre les propos de monsieur
lescure enfin tout de même il faut quand
même se rendre compte que ce que vous
êtes en train de dire au sujet des
enseignants d'abord ils ont à plusieurs
reprises dû vous indiquer qu' il était
soumis à la double peine la première
c'est qu'effectivement on veut là aussi
faire en sorte que et bien il intègre le
régime général le vôtre votre régime
soit disant universel et surtout vous le
savez pertinemment ils n'ont pas de
prime et donc à partir de là ils sont
évidemment moins bien logés que les
autres fonctionnaires et donc il ya là
un premier problème
et puis ensuite quand vous dites et bien
nous allons faire le rattrapage mais
enfin est-ce que vous pouvez là aussi
indiqué comment vous allez faire parce
qu'encore une fois rien au show fera ça
se fera au mieux à partir de 2022 2022
ce sont les élections présidentielles en
réalité vous êtes au moins en train de
faire en sorte qu'il faudra dix ans pour
arriver à tenir vos promesses
et ça aussi vous ne le dit pas vous ne
le dit pas clairement en réalité touche
si ce sont des mensonges
vous êtes en train de raconter des
mensonges aux enseignants et je ne peux
pas vous laisser dire des choses
pareilles vos promesses sont des
promesses sur dix ans et encore une fois
avec aucune certitude que le même niveau
sera atteint que ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui et vous le savez
pertinemment donc encore une fois ne
racontez pas n'importe quoi ici à la
représentation nationale
il y a là un mensonge éhonté de la part
de la majorité du gouvernement
vous êtes en train de flou et l'ensemble
des enseignants de ce pays
malade gâte merci monsieur le président
donc déjà en réponse à monsieur le
rapporteur et monsieur le ministre vous
nous dites que nos chiffres ne sont pas
bons que nous n'arrivons pas à vous
convaincre on a bien remarqué que depuis
plusieurs jours effectivement on a du
mal à se convaincre mais je mais je ne
désespère jamais donc rien ne m'empêche
de penser que d'ici quelques minutes
vous avez peut-être vous dire mais
effectivement caroline a raison une aide
soignante dans le public 1575 euros en
fin de carrière primes incluses
tout au long de sa carrière primes
incluses
on passe à 1357 euros tout ceci prime
incluse
ça fait bien moins de 118 euros donc
prouver mois par a plus b où on ne perd
pas moins de 118 euros est-ce que je
vous donne c'est avec les primes
incluses donc à quel moment on ne perd
pas à quel moment 80 % parce que ce sont
des femmes et si on est soi disant les
grandes gagnantes où et à quel moment on
va gagner avec votre système ce que je
rapelle que au lieu de partir à 57 ans
part à 64 ans +1 donc moi je veux bien
qu'on se pose
et puis alors concernant aux collègues
lescure qui vient de prendre la parole
et qui a beaucoup d'humour se trouve ce
soir il ya que deux catégories de
fonctionnaires qui sont pas trop bien
payé dans l' ocde
c'est vrai que les infirmières dans
l'eau ces deux sont très bien payés 26e
sur 29
non c'est vrai il y en a trois pires que
nous donc c'est vrai on n'est pas les
pires payer les infirmières dans le cd
eux il y en a trois pires que nous 26e
sur 29 on peut pas se contenter de ça
donc ne dit pas qui a que deux corps de
fonctionnaires bien
enfin qui ne sont pas bien rémunérés là
l'exemple que je peux vous dire c'est
que les fonctionnaires de les
infirmières 26e sur 29 dans l' ocde
il ya quand même un problème merci mais
s'il est oui oui moi je suis partisan du
débat est d'ailleurs le groupe débat et
fait des propositions
nous avons nos propres stratégies on
n'est pas d'accord ce texte mais
honnêtement monsieur le président
laissez passer des argumentaires des
argumentations des explications de cette
nature c'est pas possible
moi j'étais vert pendant 12 ans je
m'adresse à mon collègue qui est
derrière moi je n'ai jamais trafic est
dégradée et d selon pour maintenir les
gens dans la précarité et je pense que
tous les maires de france et de navarre
sont sous les mêmes valeurs
la seule chose c'est que lorsqu'on vous
dit que dans les collectivités locales
et je pense qu'on peut faire confiance
au président de l'association des maires
monsieur baroin 76% de catégorie c nous
disons que la faites attention vous
aurez un système qui va conduire à une
diminution des pensions parce que le
calcul se fait sous l'ensemble la
carrière et pas ceux des six derniers
mois donc nous sommes face à une réalité
comme ça vous cherchez à voir vous avez
précipité votre réforme la deuxième
chose c'est monsieur lescure quand vous
expliquez que vous avez rattrapé pour
les fonctionnaires non les calculs
aujourd'hui donnent très clairement et
le conseil d'état vous a fait cette
observation qui a une perte en ligne
pour les fonctionnaires notamment des
les gens de l'éducation nationale de
l'ordre de 10 à 15% et que ce que vous
vous êtes engagé à faire c'est de
rattraper par des primes mais sur une
durée donnée qui passe qui dépasse les
limites de votre pop mandat aujourd'hui
et du futur mandat d'un président qui
sera réélu à quel moment vous allez
respecter cette clause de revalorisation
par une prime
donc il ya un risque là que se sera pas
tenue pour des raisons budgétaires
monsieur madinina parole oui je ne
voudrais pas laisser l'impression de
dire qu'il n'a pas d'autre
d'autres personnes notre collègue qui
ont été maires moi j'ai été maire
pendant saison une commune de 2000
habitants et je m'occupais j'avais pas
de service direct m'occuper mois des
problèmes d'échelon et c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un
car quand dans les catégories qu'on a du
mal à les faire souvent moi j'avais je
vivais assez mal le fait de faire une
reconnaissance de certains
collaborateurs qui me semblait
nécessaire et j'étais même surpris des
rémunérations qui était relativement
basse et qui posait des problèmes
surtout quand on a des gens à temps
partiel notamment des atsem et autres
c'est un vrai souci alors on essayait
dans l'équilibré avec des primes
on essayait un petit peu de rééquilibrer
avec des primes et donc moi je qui me
rassure dans ce texte c'est qu'on va
intégrer ces primes
on va les intégrer et je crois que c'est
un argument c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème de rémunération moi je les
avancements min avant ce temps maxi ou
ceux qui ont été maires savent de quoi
je parle quand on a ces tableaux qu'on
regarde et qu'on laissait de bouger non
pas pour les triturer mais pour se
conformer à la réglementation au niveau
des échelons et aude pour moi je trouve
que ce texte va dans le bon sens parce
qu'il intègre les primes parce que c'est
un élément
alors est-ce qu'il faut avoir une
réflexion globale sur la rémunération de
la fonction territoriale
peut-être mais ça je trouve que c'est un
texte qui va dans le bon sens il faut
effectivement être vigilant pour garder
sur l'application dans le temps je suis
d'accord mais je crois pas que moi je
pourrais avoir discuté avec je dirais
des anciens je dirais salariés de ma
commune on en parle je suis encore est
juste conseil municipal mais on recoupe
pas complètement le cordon franchement
c'est une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
quand on explique merci
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes exprimés déjà donc je mets au
voir le 25 1161 les différentes
commissions des mamans qui est pour
compte
rejeter le 25 1577 qui le défend
monsieur coquerelles et je crois que par
rapport à la discussion on pourra
toujours utiliser tous les arguments
possibles imaginables
à partir du moment où vous passez d'un
système qui calculait les retraites des
fonctionnaires sur leurs 6 derniers mois
au système que vous proposez c'est à
dire le système général qui consistera
dorénavant à le faire sur toute une
carrière inévitablement vous entraîner
une baisse des retraites des
fonctionnaires
comme vous vous êtes rendu compte de ça
vous proposer de tenir compte d'une
certaine partie des primes avec j'allais
dire l'aspect aléatoire conditionnelle
peut être qui a été souligné à de
nombreuses reprises ça soit pour les
enseignants vous promettez des choses
qu'il est anticonstitutionnelle parce
que quelque part vous annoncer à
l'avancé quelque chose qui se fera dans
une loi pour la suite et on sait que ça
passera sûrement pas le cap du conseil
mensuel y compris parce que toute façon
en plus que vous promettez comme commis
encore prise en compte de prime ne
réglera pas la question et pour les
autres aussi on n'a toujours pas les
réponses jusqu'où ça ira
par contre vous dit quelque chose dans
l'article 18 amendement du gouvernement
qui va faire en sorte qu'on va passer de
5 % de cotisations sur 20 % des primes
la situation actuelle à 11,25 show 100%
donc en plus de sa non seulement vous
allez baisser les retraites des
fonctionnaires
mais vous allez également baissé leurs
revenus nets
tout au long de la carrière mais au fond
vous savez moi ce que je crois
d'ailleurs ça c'est qu'à la question de
la normalisation et progressivement ce
que j'appellerais la suppression de la
fonction publique d'état
nous avions eu votre loi sur l'acte la
loi de jean juin dernier sur de
transformation de la fonction publique
nous l'avions critiqué puisque c'était
une loi qui au nom de site et de
souplesse
dans un secteur je cite souvent victimes
de rigidité finalement preuve proposer
un recours accru aux contractuels et je
ne parle pas de la continuité de
supprimer un fonctionnaire partant à la
retraite sur deux qui pénalise l'état et
je crois que ce que vous proposez l'asse
ça c'est que vous continuez en réalité
progressivement à détruire ce qui était
une des caractéristiques de la fonction
publique pour des raisons bien précises
c'est ça le projet qui est derrière et
en plus de ça vous proposer de le faire
sur un système général qui lui-même sera
nivelé par le bas c'est la double peine
merci oui sur cet amendement de
suppression d'un ami merde ce sera un
avis des faveurs à part contre 2 points
juste repréciser que comme vous l'avez
souligné un article 18 suivre la hausse
de cotisation qui comprendra notamment
l'ensemble de la migration et donc les
primes
cette hausse s'étalera sur la durée et
que le gouvernement mais leur dira
sûrement garantit un maintien des primes
par ailleurs sur l'universalité du
système je pense qu'elle est attendue
par nos concitoyennes et concitoyens qui
aujourd'hui n'accepte plus les règles
dérogatoires alors nous avons une
opposition dessus je pense que c'est ce
qui est attendu en tout cas de nos
concitoyens d'avoir les mêmes règles qui
par ailleurs correspond davantage à la
société dans laquelle nous vivons et
dans lequel nous vivrons demain dans
laquelle nos concitoyens ont de la
mobilité professionnelle et peuvent être
durant une certaine période
fonctionnaires est plié une autre
période dans le privé ou créer une
entreprise et revenir dans la fonction
publique peut-être un moment oui et ses
règles et ce système universel qui
permettra de mieux prendre en compte ces
mobilités et c'est ce que nous devons
mettre aujourd'hui en place avis
défavorable
merci
monsieur le ministre même avec leurs
portraits du président merci alors
monsieur rebeyrotte et la parole et
monsieur dekker tous les deux attendent
depuis un certain temps donc oui la
vérité chers collègues c'est que nous
sommes sur un enjeu important
j'ai été je suis professionnellement
professeur certifié la vérité c'est que
dans la profession qu'est la mienne on
fixe le salaire le traitement de fin de
carrière et c'est sur cette base là
puisque ça va être les six derniers mois
qui vont compter pour la retraite que
l'on fait la progression de carrière
la conséquence c'est que les salaires en
entrée carrière sont extrêmement bas et
extrêmement bas par rapport aux niveaux
de qualifications exigées
conséquence de cela aujourd'hui nous ne
trouvons plus assez de jeunes qui sont
intéressés pour passer les concours et
pour rentrer dans l'enseignement c'est
qui est d'une gravité absolue je vous le
dis parce que la fonction de transfert
du savoir dans une société c'est une
fonction majeure
ce sont vraiment des personnes qui sont
au service de l'intérêt général
supérieur
or aujourd'hui ces emplois-là ces
fonctions-là n'intéresse plus personne
hélas parce que les salaires de début de
carrière sont très bas c'est une
nécessité absolue de mettre en place
cette réforme de revaloriser notamment
les salaires de début de carrière et de
ré intéresser enfin nos jeunes à rentrer
dans ces professions déterminante méfier
coquerel bien moi je trouve que se
rapportant au moins votre réponse est
claire et elle confirme la différence
que nous avons de fond sur la question
de ce qu'est la fonction publique d'état
la première chose nos concitoyens
attendent
bon c'est vrai que à force de faire un
discours anti fonctionnaires ou anti
régimes spéciaux qui laisserait penser
que les grands privilégiés nos sociétés
sont des gens qui gagnent des revenus
qui n'ont aucun rapport avec ce que vous
y avez à longueur de temps depuis deux
ans et demi je parle notamment des plus
riches de nos concitoyens à coups de
cadeaux ça évidemment à la fin
peut-être que ce discours parfois
discours anti fonctionnaires primaire
fini par percer mais je ferais remarquer
que quand on regarde en réalité les
évolutions de carrière entre la fonction
publique et le privé on voit que la
situation est loin d'être celle de
privilégier et qu'il y a certaines
choses que vivent les fonctionnaires ne
serait ce que par exemple sur le fait d
envoyer à tel ou tel endroit pour
exercer leur profession ce qui sont des
conditions qui j'allais dire peuvent
expliquer ça mais plus globalement c'est
la réponse à au moins votre réponse et
honnêtes vous dites que vous rêvez
finalement d'une société dans laquelle
on ferait des allers retours entre le
privé et le public
bon bah nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
ça nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça
et ça explique pourquoi vous allez
normaliser la question des faux sur wii
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça
parce que ça sadc a des côtés désastreux
de danse danse dans un certain milieu le
pantouflage sa a coté désastreux ou
quand un moment donné des gens qui vont
dans le privé exercer alors même qu'ils
ont été formés formé par l'état peuvent
une fois qu'ils servent aux l'état avoir
effectivement des conflits d'intérêts
qui ne sont pas acceptables nous nous
pensons qu'il faut un emploi à vie pour
les fonctionnaires s'ils le veulent
pourquoi parce que c'est live c'est la
condition pour avoir des gens qui
travaillent de façon neutre par rapport
aux intérêts à tous les intérêts y
compris financiers c'est la condition
pour avoir des gens incorruptibles c'est
la condition pour servir l'état et nous
avons donc effectivement un désaccord de
fond avec la logique qui est la vôtre
vous l'avez dit vous-même qui en réalité
vise à faire de normaliser y aura plus
grand de fonctionnaires on fera des
allers-retours offrait un rôle de
service public c'est pas c'est pas notre
modèle est en tout cas c'est pas ce qui
a fait la grandeur de ce pays depuis des
décennies parce que c'est quand même
grâce à la fonction publique d'état
qu'on a un état à peu près digne de ce
nom
merci monsieur ministre wynne ainsi
michel pas dire moi je voulais rebondir
sur cet échange
j'écoutais le député coquerel avec
attention on a fait un certain nombre de
focus par groupe de socioprofessionnels
au secrétariat d'état en préparant cette
réforme et notamment dans la nuit et
fonctionnaires en échantillon de pardon
pour le terme de fonctionnaires
représentatif et c'était intéressant de
l'entendre sur le fond ce que moi
j'entends aussi pour avoir travaillé
quatre ans éducation nationale et avoir
gardé un certain nombre de copains dans
cette activité d'enseignant c'est
intéressant d'écouter ce qu'ils sont
fonctionnaires qui disent qu'ils en ont
un peu un peu marre d'être montré du
doigt parce que ils ont un mode de
calcul de leur pension qui est de
retraite qui est différente de celle du
privé et sur le fou sur le fond quand on
discute tranquillement avec eux sont
très favorables nouveau système
ils sont très favorables par contre
qu'il souhaite évidemment que leur
niveau de pension que leurs niveaux de
pension ne baisse pas bien sûr ça c'est
clair d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement a pris des engagements très
clairs vis-à-vis des enseignants et des
enseignants chercheurs mais en même
temps je vous écoute et je lisais les
voilà il faut pas qu'on parte dans un
système d'opposition entre les uns et
les autres c'est tout l'intérêt de ce
système universel de retraite c'est de
réunir aussi bien les commerçants les
artisans les professions libérales que
les fonctionnaires que les salariés du
privé les fonctionnaires la fonction
hospitalière de la fonction territoriale
d'un fonction publique d'état et de
faire justement société ensemble au
travers de quelque chose qui est
fondateur et qui nous réunit qui est la
retraite
merci oui c'est un échange important est
que nous avions déjà d'ailleurs d'agents
étaient déjà eu sur la loi de
modernisation de la fonction publique
est loin de nous d'avoir des discours
anti fonction publique bien au contraire
c'est pour renforcer notre fonction
publique pour renforcer son attractivité
pour renforcer la reconnaissance des
métiers et tout cela a été construit
notamment sur la loi de modernisation
mais sur la loi bien entendu sur le
système universel de retraite aussi en
entendant ce que disent les agents delà
de la fonction publique et ou demain
effectivement faciliter la
reconnaissance de leur métier faciliter
l'accompagnement dans la construction
d'une carrière qui à un moment oui
peut amener un agent de la fonction
publique à vouloir pendant un certain
temps
aller dans le privé et pas pour
pantoufler c'est pas parce qu'on est
dans le secteur privé qu'on va
pantoufler ou alors créer son entreprise
ou aller dans le secteur associatif pour
ensuite revenir dedans mais ça implique
d'avoir tout de même les mêmes règles
afin de faciliter ces mobilités
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans le système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui quand pour fait 20
ans dans le secteur public et 20 ans
dans le secteur privé ou 20 ans n'en
secteur privé 20 ans dans le secteur
public on n'a pas la même retraite et
cela je pense que ce n'est plus ce n'est
plus acceptable et demain avec le
système universel
en tout cas on aura la même retraite
quel que soit le temps qu'on ait pu
passer dans l'un des différents secteurs
merci monsieur le président alors moi je
voudrais intervenir parce que j'ai été
heurté par des propos que j'ai entendus
de ce côté de l'hémicycle selon
lesquelles nous voudrions flouer les
enseignants mais qui peut vouloir flou
et les enseignants qui peut dire
objectivement que jean michel blanquer
qui a été recteur d'académie qui les
connaît si bien est la volonté de les
flots et qui peut croire à une telle
intention franchement j'ai été moi même
enseignante un temps je les connais très
bien et ils ont toute ma reconnaissance
et mon admiration
il exerce aujourd'hui un métier
difficile dans des quartiers ils sont
souvent il manque de reconnaissance
et si aujourd'hui on a ce sentiment
d'avoir chez ces enseignants de la
défiance c'est parce que justement il
exerce un métier particulièrement
difficile parce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
avoir un bac +5 pour rentrer faire le
crfp le crp euh pardon et être payé 1600
euros quand on commence alors qu'on a
fait cinq ans d'études
évidemment que cette loi de
programmation nous l'attendons et elle
est nécessaire et elle est juste et elle
est utile et d'ailleurs on peut pas dire
que ça se produira un jour parce qu'il y
aura une revalorisation pour les
nouvelles recrues dès 2021
donc tout ça c'est parfaitement faux en
réalité non non non monsieur c'est
parfaitement faux
nous allons et et et et ce texte
aujourd'hui sur les retraites justement
il eut l'occasion de leur dire que à la
fois on va maintenir leur niveau de
retraite mais également parce qu'il joue
notre reconnaissance
on va augmenter leur traitement donc moi
je peux j'ai été vraiment heurté par
votre vos propos et je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire cela
mathieu brunelle oui décidément on ne
rencontre pas forcément les mêmes
personnes seules mais dit quand je
rencontre les enseignants ils me disent
ouais c'est bien votre effort il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
bon c'est ce que huit mois quand je
rencontre les enseignants ils disent que
c'est pas bien
donc voilà on rencontre pas les mêmes
personnes s'est complètement sûr bon et
c'est normal mais normalement notre côté
vous dites que le métier d'enseignant
c'est un métier difficile partage mais
y'a pas il n'y a pas que le métier en
sont visibles le métier dans les
industries difficile dans ceux des
verreries danseuse l'automobile lundi à
ceux qui ramassent nos poubelles
ça c'est des métiers aussi lucide on
peut parler aussi de domaine hospitalier
il ya tous les métiers sont difficiles
tous les métiers sont difficiles et
après quand on parle notamment du savoir
et de transmettre le savoir majeur
partage tout à fait et quand on dit
qu'il ya des salaires très bas c'est
combien d'en parler les salaires sont
très bas mais alors est ce que parce que
les salaires sont très bas qu'il faut
absolument affilié le public et le privé
est-ce qu'on peut pas s'épanouir quand
même qui avons bloqué lundi dans la
fonction publique il est bloqué depuis
janvier et qui permet pas l'augmentation
des salaires c'est pas nous qui l'avons
fait et quand on omet à un moment donné
c'est pas parce que le oui je trais
forme de retraite c'est pas elle qui va
amener tous les problèmes de la
difficulté de tous les jours c'est pas
vous qui allez régler sentent donc
voulez pas vous attaquez véritablement à
la réalité à ce qui se passe parce qu'il
ya d'autres moyens aujourd'hui pour que
les métiers sont moins difficiles
les mortiers sont moins pénibles et les
métiers soient bien payés mais bon c'est
pas la réforme de rethel qui va poser
cette question là par contre qu'ils
voulaient une solution on en a une au
lieu de toujours niveler par le bas à
niveler par le haut pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui prendre les meilleures
années comme les fonctionnaires c'est
les six derniers mois parce qu'ils ont
fait tout un déroulement de carrière
depuis le début jusqu'à la fin
effectivement c'est les six derniers
mois ou touche le plus et ben pourquoi
on peut pas essayer de régler ça dans
l'ensemble des professions que ce soit
du privé ou du public mais donc tout le
monde pourra essayer de faire un effort
et voilà et vous le faites pas vous
restez actuellement tranché match et des
guerres
lp monsieur vélo oui monsieur le
président négoce et base sur la
revalorisation des professeurs et ou
demain l'heure le montant de leur
pension
d'abord pour rappeler à nos collègues
que notre collègue patrick hetzel qui
s'est exprimée était lui-même recteur et
qu'il ne peut pas être suspectés de ne
pas connaître la situation des
enseignants le ministre non je suis je
suis moi même je suis moi même
professeur et je voudrais vous donner
mon point de vue si on peut être
d'accord sur le partage et le constat
que les enseignants rend compte des
difficultés que leurs carrières doivent
être valorisés que le faible niveau de
traitement
comparés à leurs homologues européens
fait que nous vivons une crise des
vocations
je vous mets en garde contre l'idée de
dire que la revalorisation qui est
projeté va résoudre tous les problèmes
d'abord pour une bonne raison c'est que
cette revalorisation ça a été affiché a
pour seul but de compenser les pertes à
venir au moment de la retraite
une fois la retraite arrivée et et vous
ne pouvez pas le nier
là pour le coup il ya eu des simulations
très précise et parmi les enseignants
d'ailleurs qui sont les moins bien
rémunérés
les professeurs des écoles peuvent se
préparer à des pertes considérables
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas normal que que
la représentation nationale négligent à
ce point la situation de ces enseignants
dont le rôle est capital qui exercent
dans des conditions difficiles
soyez prudent lorsque vous évoquez
revalorisation aussi parce que elle est
tellement étalée dans le temps que vous
laisser le soin aux autres de la mettre
en oeuvre
moi je vous invite à beaucoup plus de
prudence et puis je voulais dire je
voulais évoquer la question des
catégories ses employés la question des
catégories c des agents territoriaux
j'avais eu l'occasion de le dire
on parle aussi on parle beaucoup ce soir
de déprime qui viendraient là aussi
compenser demander votre aide qui évolué
à la baisse
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire j'ai été
président d'un département j'ai eu à
avoir connaissance de retraite qui
n'excédait pas 953
euros pour des personnes qui avaient
participé pendant des années à des
travaux de déneigement des tâches elle
aussi qui correspond qui rencontrent des
difficultés
aujourd'hui chacun le sait il y à autant
de régimes indemnitaires que deux
collectivités
il y a notamment dans les petites
communes des fonctionnaires de cette
catégorie qui ont des primes qui sont
négligeables
et donc là aussi soyez très prudent
parce que je pense que imaginer que les
primes seront la bouée de sauvetage de
votre système
cc c'est périlleux et vous allez créer
autant de pension de retraite qu'il y à
deux régimes indemnitaires dans ce pays
ce qui pour le coup va mettre à mal
l'universalité supposé devons maintenant
ou à la parole pourquoi il ya tout lieu
de douter de la réalité des
revalorisations et de la réalité de la
compensation des pensions pour les
enseignants mais comme sans doute
beaucoup d'autres fonctionnaires dans le
cadre de la nouvelle réforme
la réponse elle est dans l'étude
d'impact les projections qui sont faites
leçons sur la base d'un système actuel
dégradée en dépit du bon sens avec une
augmentation de la part des primes qui
concentre l'essentiel de des gains de
pouvoir d'achat des enseignants pendant
toute leur carrière et qui conduit à ce
qu'au moment où ils prennent leur
pension ils ont dans les hypothèses de
l'étude d'impact un niveau de
rémunération qui a décroché par rapport
au salaire moyen du reste de la
population et c'est ce qui permet
comparant ce système qui n'existe pas et
qui n'existera jamais puisqu'il est
totalement truquée de dire vous voyez le
nouveau système
ils dégradent pas tellement le niveau
des pensions avec cette revalorisation
départ les primes qui vont compter dans
le calcul des droits à la retraite
mais c'est en réalité
une duperie complète qui permet en
réalité de sous-évaluer grandement
grandement le niveau nécessaire pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de perte de pension ça
c'est la première chose et c'est cette
étude d'impact elle est scandaleuse
elle est scandaleuse ensuite pourquoi
douter bas parce que le premier acte du
gouvernement vis-à-vis des professeurs a
été un de recommencer en réduire le
nombre
en rayonnant à bastille on a créé tutu
bien placé pour le savoir parce que tu
soutenais cette majorité
je te rappelle je te rappelle que nous
voyons est de rigueur en cercles legs
d'espoir mans est de rigueur
son plus beau scruter recréer redescend
heureux destruction et salissant des
revalorisations alignement des régimes
d'aidés régime de primes des enseignants
du premier degré du jeune second degré
ça a été fait ça coûtait 300 millions
d'euros par an ensuite ppsr vous
respecte et allemandes dialogue social
que la première chose que vous avez été
fait c'est de ne pas respecter le
produit la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux ppcr vous n'avez pas
dégeler le point d'indicé comme c'était
prévu dans la négociation et vous n'avez
pas appliquée ppsr en 2008 vous l'avez
reportez vous le paierez en 2021
l'argent de 2008 que vous l'aurez pas
versée et on pourrait aller tout est à
l'avenant
il n'y a aucune raison de vous faire
confiance sur ce point est en tout cas
les enseignants font pas confiance à
leurs ministres sa parole
merci monsieur le président un petit mot
on peut douter on peut mettre en cause
effectivement les annonces du ministre
blanc caire pour autant moi je peux vous
dire que chez les jeunes enseignants qui
viennent d'embrasser la carrière par
conviction 100 euros par mois 1200 euros
par an ça parle et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya une écoute et une attente très
forts de cette mesure dans les classes
j'ai enseigné pendant trente ans le
métier je connais par coeur
l'universalité de ce régime de retraite
effectivement la possibilité dorénavant
d'avoir une retraite qui soit calculé de
la même façon pour les gens du public où
les gens du privé
je peux vous dire que c'est attendu
aussi parce qu'une femme carrière quand
on a passé 30 ans dans une école il ya
un phénomène d'usure il ya peut-être une
aspiration à exercer un autre métier est
en tout cas cette possibilité
aujourd'hui d'aligner les différents
régimes
eh ben ça permettra aussi à certains de
basculer vers d'autres carrières en ce
qui concerne la fonction publique
territoriale
j'entendais tout à l'heure les gens qui
ont été maires j'ai eu la chance de
l'être est effectivement bien souvent
les fonctionnaires de la catégorie c on
permet de valoriser leurs engagements
parce qu'on a ce régime indemnitaire qui
permet d'ajouter 50 100 euros pour avoir
un régime qui correspond à l'engagement
de ces personnes alors effectivement ce
régime indemnitaire dorénavant il va
être intégrée intégrés dans les
retraites et ben je crois que là aussi
c'est quelque chose qui est très attendu
je suis encore conseiller municipal de
la commune où j'étais mère et je peux
vous dire que les agents de catégorie c
ils sont très à l'écouté et très
désireux en tout cas que ce régime se
mette en place le plus rapidement
possible
merci donc nous allons maintenant voter
sur cet amendement c'est un vote à main
levée défavorable commission
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
rejeté le 21 1594 map y est je suis le
président donc j'entendais tout à
l'heure un collègue dire qu'il y avait
un souci pour donner envie aux gens de
rentrer dans la fonction publique ce que
les sages les salaires d'entrée n'était
pas suffisant enfin nous parler des
salaires d'entrée sur le projet de loi
des retraites
je comprends pas ton mais si
effectivement le salaire des
fonctionnaires est à revoir
je pense qu'il faudrait en faire un
projet de loi et on seraient nombreux à
voter sur nos bancs pour augmenter les
salaires
en tout cas dans la fonction publique
hospitalière ça fait trois ans qu'on
attend je me suis trompé c'est pour ça
monsieur le ministre que vous ne m'avez
pas répondu ce que j'ai pas pu vous
convaincre je ne me suis trompé tout à
l'heure dans mon exemple quand je vous
ai pris l'exemple d'une aide soignante
josé 10575 euros en fin de carrière
c'était sans prime et 1357 en moyenne
avec prime voilà d'où le et donc moins
de 118 euros de pertes mais elle perd 2
118 euros en travaillant sept ans de
plus
l'aide soignante va travailler sept ans
de plus et perte de 118 euros dans le
calcul de sa retraite
à quel moment cette personne est
gagnante
et vous savez depuis tout à l'heure je
n'arrête pas d'entendre cette musique
cette petite musique la différence entre
le public et le privé où il ya toujours
eu des jalousies entre le public et le
privé et je vais vous le dire très
simplement ce qu'on méritait d'être
saignant dans un ehpad privé et
effectivement il y avait cette jalousie
à se dire que les collègues dans le
public elle pouvait partir plus tôt et
vie bizarre moi et mes collègues jamais
on s'est dit pourquoi les collègues du
public elles partiraient plus tard mais
par contre on se disait pourquoi dans
l'hémicycle pourquoi l'assemblée
nationale personne n'a l'idée de se dire
que tout les aides-soignantes que ce
soit dans le privé ou dans le public
puissent partir plus tôt parce que nos
corps sont fatigués voile exact et je
n'avais aucune en bis les écoutons
madame fiat
vous savez tout à l'heure quand ma
collègue et l'image parlé il ya eu une
belle phrase quelqu'un a dit un peu de
respect une femme parle et je sais pas
avait remarqué je suis aussi une femme
donc à l'époque favols n'ai jamais eu
l'ambition et je ne pensais jamais
arrivé sur ces bandes mais maintenant
que j'y suis je ne vois pas pourquoi je
ne porterais puis cette parole que
j'avais au moment des transmissions avec
mes collègues
donc si il ya une jalousie un moment
donné entre le privé et le public c'est
pour que le privé puisse acquérir ces
mêmes droits que le public et non pas
punir le public pour eux si ce qu'ils
soient punis comme dans le privé
merci d'evra monsieur le ministre
monsieur ministe défavorable monsieur je
n'y ai à monsieur le président on vient
d'évoquer la question de l'attractivité
en particulier du métier d'enseignant et
la carrière d'enseignant
bien évidemment il ya la question de la
rémunération bien sûr que c'est un sujet
mais il faut pas oublier non plus le
facteur conditions de travail et
aujourd'hui si vous regardez bien il n'y
a jamais eu aussi peu de candidats pour
les postes aux concours d'enseignants
c'est le résultat de monsieur lancker
donc bon jamais jamais il ya eu jamais
jamais dans l'histoire
jamais dans l'histoire alors lui aussi
tu es quelque chose des chiffres
j'espère cela vous les accepterai
monsieur le ministre
ces cieux de la dares la direction de
l'animation des études la statistique du
ministère du travail
elle a publié une étude très
intéressante c'est comme l'adresse c'est
comme l'insee c'est très intéressant la
statistique
une radiographie des risques
professionnels dans la fonction publique
et l'a comparé au secteur privé et c'est
quoi
les conclusions de cette radiographie
c'est que les fonctionnaires sont
souvent plus exposés que les salariés du
privé à la pénibilité
et cette étude al extrêmement complète
parce qu'il ya aussi les risques
psychosociaux il ya aussi les
contraintes physiques organisationnel
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
alors bien évidemment il ya la fonction
publique territoriale puisque là on a
des contraintes postural on a les
nuisances sonores et thermique
bien évidemment et les facteurs de
pénibilité cumulatif on a cité un
certain nombre de métiers tout à l'heure
et puis au delà des enseignants très
clairement c'est la fonction publique
hospitalière qui est de loin la plus
exposée puisqu'en plus des contraintes
physiques
en plus des contraintes horaires en plus
d'un contact avec le public parfois
difficile et puis le sentiment de ne pas
avoir les moyens et le temps d'effectuer
son travail correctement
on sait que dans la fonction publique
hospitalière le personnel est plus
souvent en syndrome d'épuisement
professionnel ce qu'on appelle le burn
out
58% des personnels hospitaliers souffre
d'un manque de reconnaissance 35% de la
situation de tension et 20% font même
face à des comportements hostiles donc
ce que je voulais dire c'est que vous
vous vantez que vous allez élargira la
fonction publique le le cdp mais le cdpc
de la version dégradée du c3 paie donc
quatre critères de pénibilité en moins
donc c'est une version d'un pénibilité
dégradée que vous allez offrir aux hauts
fonctionnaires
et puis vous dites 60 ans ils pourront
partir mais non pas du tout avec la
pénibilité ça c'est lâche théorique avec
l'âge des équilibres vous aurez
forcément lemalu financiers et donc vous
allez obliger ces travailleurs et
notamment ses fonctionnaires à
travailler plus longtemps
deux ans plus et donc à partir dans un
état de santé encore plus dégradée merci
merci monsieur le président je voulais
réagir
un autre collègue qui nous expliquait
tout à l'heure que en fait on devrait
avoir toute une carrière soit donc privé
ou soit dans le public
je pense pas que ce soit le mode de
décider de la carrière des français en
fait aujourd'hui je pense que nous
faisons tous le constat que le monde
évolue de plus en plus vite et il
évoluera de plus en plus vite
la technologie évolue vite les moyens de
communication évoluent de façon produit
est révolu
et et notre façon de concevoir aussi
évolué il faut toujours apprendre une
toux faut toujours nous adapter et et
nos envies et nos ambitions aussi évolué
et à des moments spécifiques de notre
vie on peut vouloir produire concevoir
conseiller enseigner et on peut vouloir
le faire dans le monde public ou dans le
monde privé c'est voilà on ne veut
partager son savoir-faire veut partager
son expérience et on veut le pouvoir le
faire dans tous les domaines et donc
c'est notre rôle aujourd'hui de
permettre à chacun de nos concitoyens
d'avoir c'est évolution de vie ces
mouvements dans la vie voilà et notre
système de retraite doit être capable de
permettre ces différents mouvements sur
merci merci cher collègue monsieur
dharréville
oui merci monsieur président bien c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui que dans ce pays un
certain nombre de forces politiques et
sociales essaye de diviser les
travailleurs et travailleuses en
expliquant qu' il y aurait d'un côté le
public de l'autre le privé et que les
agents du public seraient des
privilégiés par rapport à ceux du privé
nous nous savons qu'il existe évidemment
des spécificités des sujétions
différente lorsqu'on est un d'un agent
de la fonction publique
on a une responsabilité singulière dans
le cadre de la république elle même mais
pour autant nous refusons cette volonté
de diviser qui ne se fonde sur rien que
sur la volonté de continuer à organiser
la régression sociale dans le pays on a
vu d'ailleurs les régimes dégringoler
les uns après les autres par un
phénomène d'escalier comme ça que l'on
que l'on descend c'est vrai que il ya
une dureté dans le privé des relations
sociales particulières pas partout elle
et elle est pas uniforme
cette dureté elles existent parfois
aussi dans le secteur public sous des
formes différentes mais elles existent
aussi elle s'est aggravée ces dernières
années il ya une quête de compétitivité
qui pèsent sur les corps sur les esprits
sur les femmes et les hommes qui qui
travaillent
bon voilà tout ça nous le savons il ya
des parcours différents ça n'empêche pas
d'arrières les carrières hybride et elle
existe déjà avec des passerelles
vous avez effectué un certain nombre de
réformes en ce sens dont nous avons
interrogé le sens parce que il nous
semblait que c'était tout à fait
nécessaire il ya eu des évolutions dans
les statuts dans les parcours et c est
moi ce que je crois au fond c'est que il
y à une dégradation du travail dans la
société et que vous voulez y faire
correspondre une dégradation de la
retraite voilà la vérité pour moi de
votre projet or je constate quand je lis
l'étude d'impact je voudrais vous redire
cette phrase qui a la page 149
sur laquelle certain nombre de gens ont
essayé de passer un peu rapidement les
taux de remplacement soit la différence
entre le dernier revenus d'activité et
la retraite des agents publics y sont
équivalents à ceux des salariés
malgré ces règles différentes or vous
comme vous essayez de mettre toutes
façons étals toutes les règles de façon
et al et bien vous allez mettre en péril
cette équité du taux de remplacement
s'ils existent aujourd'hui
merci les groupes qui ont souhaité
s'exprimer sont exprimés non ils sont
exprimés sur du verger s'est exprimé non
monsieur diverger et exprimez vous êtes
exprimés donc je me revois l'amendement
21 1594 bah oui ce sera pour la
prochaine fois reviennent à la prochaine
foire 21 1595 je peux pas coordonnées à
l'intérieur du groupe dont là mais la
prochaine fois on vous donnera la parole
qui est pour un amendement qui compte
rejeté le maintien 1612 qui le défend
monsieur caténaires merci monsieur le
président je profitais la défense de cet
amendement pour reparler la situation
particulière des enseignants qui
anticipe que cette réforme des retraites
va procéder pour est une baisse de leur
pension de 30% a effectivement on a bien
entendu que il y avait des
revalorisations très importante de prévu
mais on a eu l'occasion de vous dire
déjà qu'elle n'était pas à la hauteur
notamment s'agissant de ce que va être
l'inflation qui plus est l'étude
d'impact sur les enseignants les
professeurs montrent que pour pouvoir
obtenir une hausse de leur niveau de
pension les fonctionnaires de
l'éducation devront partir à 67 ans et
que c'est à partir d'un départ à 67 ans
que possiblement leur pension elle a
augmenté c'est ce qu'indique c'est ce
qu'indique effectivement l'étude
d'impact donc clairement nouveau re
disons les choses il
faut renoncer à cette règle qui vise à
calculer la pension sur la base de
l'ensemble de la carrière cela a du sens
de considérer compte tenu de ce que sont
les carrières que pour les
fonctionnaires on en reste sur les six
derniers mois
c'est valable pour les enseignants c'est
valable pour les ensembles l'ensemble
des agents de la fonction publique et de
la même manière pour les salariés du
privé dont nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure et bien les 25 meilleures années
sont effectivement sens et jusque là à
l'envers ce les carrières ne sont pas
linéaires je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
le débat a eu lieu à plusieurs reprises
à vis des savants monsieur le ministre
le ma vie m similienne voiliers a pas de
problème on vous écoute
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues j'ai entendu des choses tout à
l'heure sur notamment son milieu de
l'éducation nationale qui m'ont choqué
on nous avons un très très bon ministre
de l'éducation nationale le dédoublement
des classes c'est lui ça c'est une
mesure de justice sociale
d'accord pour ce qui concerne les
enseignants il va y avoir une
consultation au mois de mars pas
seulement avec les syndicats avec
l'ensemble des enseignants ça aussi
c'est une nouvelle façon de travailler
que les enseignants et puis je veux bien
qu'on se gausse sur la revalorisation
salariale de 100 euros à partir de 2021
mais c'est la première fois que ça
arrive depuis 1989 alors ni à droite ni
à gauche
vous n'avez rien fait depuis 89 pour les
enseignants
merci monsieur monsieur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur mais je vous en prie vous chers
collègues
monsieur dharréville souhaité s'exprimer
puis merci merci monsieur le président
mais je vois notre collègue du modem a
oublié quelques épisodes au passage bon
mais ils y ont été rappelés ici par un
bar l'assemblée parce que je pense qu'il
ya eu un vice de l'éducation au passage
qui a dû s'appeler françois bayrou un
moment donné me semble-t-il mais bien
c'était pas le sujet de mon intervention
je voudrais vous faire part de la
réflexion de thomas amos et de joannie
cayouette ramblière qui paru dans
libération il ya quelques semaines de ça
qui dit la chose suivante
ce projet de réforme donc ne ferait que
prolonger les inégalités de carrière
entre fonctionnaires et salariés du
privé qui se sont fortement accentués
avec les politiques conduites depuis 15
ans entre 2014 et 2017
les fonctionnaires exerçant un emploi de
niveau supérieur dont font partie
notamment les 900 mille enseignants mais
aussi les médecins hospitaliers ou
encore les hauts fonctionnaires ont
perçu en moyenne 2000 668 euros nets
mensuels primes comprises avant impôt
contre 3508 pour les salariés du privé
en cdi
de même niveau de qualification voilà ça
c'est une réalité je pense qu'ils
méritent aussi d'être d'être souligné au
passage quand on parle de carrière et
donc de retraite et donc il indique que
la chose suivante en appliquant à toutes
et à tous le mode de calcul des
retraites le moins avantageux
le projet de réforme joue la carte d'un
nivellement par le bas
les données statistiques montrent qu'il
se traduirait de plus et surtout par une
pénalisation des fonctionnaires de
niveau intermédiaire et supérieure par
rapport aux salariés en cdi du privé
voilà la réforme les résultats de la
réforme que vous nous proposez je crois
qu'à un moment donné il va falloir qu'un
que vous la regardiez en face merci
oui merci monsieur le président
j'entends nos collègues du modem
effectivement qui ont été longtemps
représenté par un autre ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui a pas laissé
une mémoire un souvenir mémorable dans
le corps des enseignants mais mais je
voudrais faire ce constat là mes chers
collègues quand on a parlé avant la
semaine je crois lundi soir des sapeurs
pompiers on nous a dit non non non non
les sapeurs pompiers ça sera traitée
dans le cadre d'une preuve d'une ppl
porté par le groupe
quand on a parlé des agriculteurs pas
plus tard que cette fin de tout à
l'heure on nous a dit mais non non on va
mettre en place une commission pour
réfléchir là j'entends que sur les
enseignants on aura une conférence au
mois de mars pour une consultation qui
est inédite
on va consulter ou même mars sauf qu'on
vote le texte on nous propose de voter
le texte maintenant et qui plus est le
financement de ce texte sera connu en
avril
non mais où est la logique franchement
si quelqu'un retrouve quelque chose
qu'on me fasse signe
et puis je voudrais rappeler oui bah
c'est bien il doit y avoir que vous
monsieur
comme quoi au final rend alors on me
dira de compensation je suis atterré que
vous puissiez considérer qu'aujourd'hui
vous traitiez bien les enseignants parce
que vous leur offrez une augmentation de
rémunération
c'est une petite compensation par
rapport à leur perte de recettes
possibles potentiel dans l'avenir par
rapport à leurs revenus de retraite
d'aujourd'hui il ya une telle perte que
ça ne compensera jamais et vous pouvez
même pas parler d'augmentation c'est une
faible compensation
merci madame t-il à la parole merci
monsieur le président j'entendais notre
collègue du modem et sûrement d'autres
qui étaient presque à se fâcher que les
enseignants du premier degré ne soit pas
d'accord alors hein on a le droit de ne
pas être d'accord
2 je voudrais savoir qui ici a vécu
toute une vie entière avec un salaire
d'instit parce que quand on dit qu'on
gagne 1600 euros
au début c'est pas qu'au début c'est
pendant 15 ans et au bout de 15 ans qui
est quand même extraordinaire c'est
qu'on à 1700 et on a mille sept cent
pendant dix ans et vous savez combien
d'années en mai pour avoir 2000
cinq ans est en fin de carrière enfin
juste avant d'être élu à 35 ans de
carrière miracle on gagne 2500 oui on
donne des cours particuliers toute sa
vie pour s'en sortir donc un lien moment
quand même est-ce que vous avez déjà
vécu avec une paye d'un site
vient ensuite la deuxième chose on n'est
pas là pour faire le procès on n'est pas
là pour faire le procès des actionnaires
je souhaite pouvoir je souhaite juste
pour mes frères on n'est pas là pour
faire le procès des anciens ministres
dont on se fiche éperdument c'est le
présent qu'on fait monsieur blanc le
nôtre ministre blanc caire n'a rien à
voir la consultation qui se fait c'est
concerne ça concerne les drh ce sera une
énième consultation de plus pourvu
qu'elles soient mieux prises en compte
que les états généraux de la bioéthique
mais ce sera quand même une énième
consultation ça n'a rien à voir
laissez les 12 élèves en cp ça n'a rien
à voir avec la retraite
la question est quand même c'est pour
que les enseignants conserve les mêmes
montants de retraite qu'aujourd'hui il
faudrait augmenter de 25 à 30% leur
rémunération
c'est quand même un vrai souci ma
question est j'ai bien entendu que il y
aurait 10 milliards 400 millions par an
on ne sait pas ni comment ça va être
financé moi j'entends mes collègues qui
n'y croient pas et comme le point un
indice n'a jamais été dégelés je les
comprends aussi faux on n'a pas de prime
est rien le problème c'est comment vous
pouvez m'assurer qu'un prochain
gouvernement entérine et applique une
loi de programmation qui est à la base
un teint constitutionnel je vous
remercie
merci merci monsieur le président vont
d'abord clairement le problème de
constitutionnalité a été posée mais qui
plus est la revalorisation salariale
qu'il faudrait mettre en place serait
absolument importante et notre collègue
dalloz parlais à l'instant d'une
compensation mais notre point de vue
c'est un piètre des dommages ont en
réalité parce qu'une revalorisation
c'est autre chose une revalorisation ça
veut dire c'est une reconnaissance en
quelque sorte du métier d'enseignant et
donc on prend acte du fait que depuis
trop d'années ils sont sous payés moins
payés que dans les autres pays de l'
ocde et que donc il doit être revalorisé
mais que n'avez vous fait en presque
trois ans que vous êtes aux affaires
pour attendre que cette réforme des
retraites se fasse et que parce qu'elle
va avoir pour principale conséquence de
baisser considérablement le niveau des
pensions des enseignants là vous vous
dites ça il faut compenser mais en
réalité ce n'est pas ça revalorisé
d'autant plus qu'on a entendu dans la
bouche du ministre blanc caire le fait
que potentiellement leur mission
pourrait être vu ou qu'on pourra leur
demander d'autres petites choses ça
c'est pas une revalorisation
c'est juste un piètre dédommagement
parce que cette réforme des retraites va
considérablement affaiblir le niveau de
leurs pensions voilà tout ce que vous
faites si vous aviez véritablement voulu
revaloriser le salaire des enseignants
vous l'auriez déjà fait vous n'auriez
pas attendu ce projet de réforme des
retraites donc ce que vous faites c'est
juste une bien maigre compensation un
petit dédommagement pour essayer
d'amortir le choc considérable que va
représenter sur le niveau de pension des
enseignants
votre réforme des retraites qui plus est
effectivement les alertes de nos
collègues sont tout à fait justifiées
puisque nous n'avons aucune garantie que
cela va pouvoir se faire le conseil
d'état vous l'a dit la promesse de cette
revalorisation n'est pas fondé d'un
point de vue constitutionnel elles
pourraient être retoqués donc très
clairement
encore une fois c'est une tartufferie de
la même manière qu'à l'article 5 nous
avons exactement le même cas de figure
avec les agriculteurs à savoir de
grandes promesses que vous faisiez mais
dont vous n'êtes pas en capacité de les
traduire dans votre texte de loi
clairement ce texte de loi
ces éléments de langage sur éléments de
langage et dès qu'on regarde plus
précisément ce qui se passe de manière
opérationnelle s'est on verra plus tard
peut-être on espère que mais jamais
d'engagement concret sinon effectivement
vos belles paroles qui ne sont valables
que pour ceux qui veulent y croire
merci mais la nation à la parole
voilà je note que le président cherchait
un petit peu mon nom donc je m'exprime
peut-être pas assez
puisqu'on parle des instits bah voila
moi je suis enseignante j'étais
enseignante jusqu'à la veille de mon
élection je suis né en 74 et
accessoirement je rapporte les crédits
enseignement scolaire à la commission
des finances
donc j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses qui
m'ont un petit peu fâché ce soir alors
d'abord dire qu'on n'a rien fait et
quand même un peu gonflé on est
l'enseignement scolaire est redevenu le
premier budget de la nation il est en
constante augmentation depuis le début
du mandat
moi j'ai fait vingt ans de rêve dans les
quartiers prioritaires les gamins les
familles qui galère je sais ce que c'est
et oui le métier a changé le métier a
changé parce que on se prend en pleine
face tous les maux toutes les douleurs
toutes les difficultés d'une société et
bon sang de bonsoir les cp à 12
j'en ai rêvé toute ma vie
j'ai connu aussi les années 2007 2008
2009 la suppression des effectifs
les rased en moins les les assistants
d'éducation qui disparaissait et les
personnels pour nous aider à accompagner
les enfants porteurs de handicap il y
avait plus personne dans nos classes on
nous avait vidé de nos effectifs mois
les a's qui ont un vrai contrat qui ont
un vrai statut qui sont rentrés dans un
galop social j'en ai rêvé toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
et on va régler une bonne fois pour
toute cette histoire de problèmes de
constitutionnalité
le problème de constitutionnalité c'est
parce qu'on on peut juste pas donner une
injonction au gouvernement ça veut pas
dire qu'on va pas le faire sur sauf sur
la loi de programme de de programmation
je m'engage devant tout le monde puisque
je suis à la commission des finances et
que je rapporte les crédits de
l'enseignement scolaire
je mettrai mon nez dans c'est notre
travail de parlementaires de vérifier et
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement
prenons en charge cette responsabilité
ray et soyons fiers du travail que l'on
fait tous les jours et dernières
remarques quand on est né en 75 et qu'on
a eu son concours comme moi dans les
années 90 97
on part pas en retraite deux mains moi
j'ai encore 20 ans de carrière fin avec
cinq ans ou dix ans de parenthèses
[Rires]
mais on part pas en retraite demain c
510 millions qu on a 1000 cette année
ses 510 millions qu on rajoutera encore
et c'est inscrit dans les crédits sont
inscrits dans le temps et on partira pas
quand on est né en 74 75 et qu'on aille
son concours en 97 ou en 90 ans partent
en retraite demain donc on a le temps de
2,2 de programmer tout ça alors je mets
je vais mettre aux voix de 21 1612
défavorable commission et gouvernement
qui est pour l'adoption d'amendements
qui est contre rejeté
nous en venons au 28 1629
j'annonce que la france a soumis une
demande structure publique qui sera
organisée sur cet amendement
le scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée nationale qui le présente
[Musique]
doit rappels au règlement
pour s'inscrire qui le présente il est
défendu d favorable défavorable
monsieur bazin la parole
pour pouvoir parler des professeurs
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors je
suis un prime aux députés comme certains
d'entre vous mais j'ai pas la prétention
que avant notre avant ce quinquennat
tout était noir et j'ai pas non plus le
l'impression que depuis ce quinquennat
tout est blanc et donc en septembre 2010
il y a eu une revalorisation pour plus
d'un milliard d'euros pour les jeunes
enseignants ils ont envie bénéficiaires
c'est vrai parce que je pense qu'il faut
être juste aussi dans les explications
c'était lié à une réforme de leur
formation les recrues tant au niveau
master 2 donc bac +5 et donc il ya eu 2
décret statutaire comme quoi on est
capables d'intervenir à tout moment dès
décret statutaire du 2 août 2010 et du
26 août 2010 avec des bonifications
d'ancienneté sur la grille indiciaire
puisque comme il commençait un an plus
tard voilà et je continue si vous me le
permettez monsieur président mignola il
ya eu d'autres mesures indemnitaire
notamment sur les fonctions intérêts
collectifs mais aussi par rapport aux
enseignants qui étaient en charge
d'enfants handicapés
comme quoi la prise en charge du
handicap n'a pas commencé non plus avec
ce ce quinquennat et je crois que c'est
important de ne pas avoir une vision
complètement idéaliste mais surtout ne
pas réécrire l'histoire
car en caricaturant le passé vous
n'allez pas générer de la confiance vous
prenez même le risque de la méfiance
quand vous prétendez écrire l'avenir de
la retraite de nos enseignants
merci monsieur dufrègne oui monsieur le
président en fait en fait je crois que
vous êtes les rois de l'entourloupe
plus personne ne vous croit et les
français de moins en moins et petit à
petit tout ce que vous dites est entaché
de suspicion tout à l'heure pour les
agriculteurs vous vous êtes enorgueilli
de faire la retraite à 1000 euros pour
tous ceux qui prendront leur retraite à
partir de 2022
seul moins de la moitié seront concernés
les agents de catégorie c de la fonction
publique territoriale avec des petites
primes 1 auront avec un calcul sur toute
la carrière une pension inférieure à
celle qu'ils auraient pu en prenant le
six derniers mois avec vous tout le
monde sera content on ne doit pas
rencontrer les mêmes gens monsieur
lescure parlait de fonctionnaires bien
payés c'est quoi une bonne paye quant
aux enseignants
quant aux enseignants ce n'est pas une
revalorisation vous l'avez dit vous-même
mais plutôt une avance sur leurs futures
pensions alors un peu de modestie et
monsieur petit
oui merci monsieur le président moi je
vous y revenir quand même sur cette
histoire de deux conflits d'intérêts et
de passages de fonctionnaires privée je
crois pas que l'honnêteté soit faite par
la loi et je crois pas non plus que
l'engagement et la capacité d'engagement
soit faite par le fait qu on est
fonctionnaire ou pas je crois moi j'ai
fait beaucoup d'allers retours je crois
que ce qui est important c'est d'être
utile
c'est d'être utile je vais vous donner
un exemple la fonction publique va
changer aussi j'ai été très intéressé
par ce que dit monsieur dharréville sur
la dégradation du travail je crois pas
que le travail se dégradent je crois que
le travail change et donc il faut pas
faire la relation entre le travail qui
se dégradent et la retraite qui se
dégrade
il faut faire la relation entre le
travail qu'ils changent et les retraites
qui changent et les rémunérations qui
changent et les carrières qui changent
et je vous donne un exemple sur la
fonction publique
la fonction publique aussi va changer
la fonction publique aussi va avoir
d'autres métiers on pourrait déjà avoir
un bon service informatique à
l'assemblée nationale on pourrait on
pourrait quand même on pourrait quand
même on pourrait quand même mais ils le
savent ils le savent que je suis en
colère tous les jours mais ils le savent
mais je vais vous donner un exemple plus
important nous avons un ministère et ça
va vous faire plaisir
nous avons un ministère de la transition
écologique ce que j'appelle - la
transition ça veut dire le changement
nous avons un ministère du changement il
y a un métier qui aujourd'hui réservé à
des gens que vous allez appeler des gens
comme que qu'aimerait bien le présent
lescure ou moi même mais il y a un
métier qui existe depuis une dizaine
d'années dans le monde qui s'appelle
manager du changement ok des managers de
la transition
il n'y a pas un manager de la transition
dans le ministère de la transition
il y a des bons électricien il y à des
spécialistes de la géologie il n'y a
personne qui est capable et qui sait
quel est le métier de la transformation
d'un groupe social c'est un métier qui
aujourd'hui ne fait pas partie des
métiers de la fonction publique alors
que nous en crevant je vous remercie
merci alors monsieur petit si vous avez
des soucis d'informatique n'hésitez pas
à vous adresser aux questeurs c'est
indispensable de mettre en cause des
fonctionnaires de l'assemblée ici
surtout à l'occasion de ce débat
merci y avait-il d'autres prises de
parole tous les groupes se sont exprimés
monsieur madame 1 bis ap merci monsieur
le président et je regrette parce que je
n'ai toujours pas eu de réponse sur le
fait de m'expliquer à quel moment on
gagne oui c'est vrai comme le dit
monsieur minos j'ai peut-être jamais
avoir de réponse mais c'est pas grave
j'ai un caractère qui fait que je
continuerai à poser mes questions
218 euros de pertes sur une aide
soignante qui va travailler sept ans de
plus bah écoutez ça vous agace peut-être
mais enfin je pense qu' il n'y a pas que
moi qui souhaitent avoir cette réponse
dehors et j'entends le collègue petit
qui nous dit que il ya une personne qui
parle
ouais j'ai entendu collègues du meuble
merci monsieur le président j'ai entendu
le collègue petit qui nous explique que
les métiers ont changé en moi ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que effectivement
les métiers ont peut-être changé mais
pas pas forcément mieux et on a envie de
penser que dans le monde dans le milieu
hospitalier
les soins sont à peu près toujours les
mêmes ce même si effectivement il ya eu
une amélioration dans le matériel
mais vous voyez aujourd'hui agathe
infirmière s'est fait tabasser par un
patient mécontent de sa prise en charge
ça c'est devenu aussi un vrai quotidien
havrais quotidien qu'on doit ici prendre
en compte et il ya aussi cette
souffrance de se dire que partout on va
d quelqu'un dit qu'il travaille dans la
fonction publique il y à cette
connotation à côté
où ce serait des feignants des moins que
rien et il ya toujours cette connotation
non mais est ce que j'ai dit sur ces
bancs arrêté je vous parle dans la vie
en général
arrêtez de tout prendre sur votre compte
et et tout ceci c'est bien sûr ces
banques ça doit se régler
et quand on explique qu'il faut
supprimer un avantage de la fonction
publique pour les mettre à égalité du
privé c'est continuer à faire en sorte
que ces bruits continue à courir et non
je ne peux pas entendre dire que les
métiers se sont arrangées que les
métiers se sont améliorées parce que la
pénibilité a augmenté parce que profiter
et espérer sur des algorithmes comme
nous l'a dit tout à l'heure monsieur
ollier pour dire qu'on avait moins
besoin d'avocat moins besoin
d'infirmiers on voit le résultat à
l'heure actuelle donc non il ya des
vraies difficultés et pouvoir laisser
partir les gens partir un âge décent
avec une retraite décente quand ils
donnent leur vie pour sauver la vie des
autres pour vous soigner pour nous
soigner
il y avait quelque chose de cohérent
madame du billet puis notre reporter
général
oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement cet article pose je pense
le vrai sujet en ce qui concerne le
passage à un régime universel pour
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires des trois
fonctions publiques
on sait qu'en moyenne les primes
représentent 22 % du salaire
et personne dans cet hémicycle ne peut
imaginer que
ces primes seront intégrés dans leur
totalité et qu'à terme le fonctionnaire
alors que lorsqu'il part à la retraite
sa retraite est calculée sur 75% de
lundi ce qu'il a acquis dans les six
derniers mois
jamais forcément il y aura une baisse du
taux de remplacement ça peut pas être
autrement dans la mesure où les points
seront calculés depuis le début de la
carrière où il commencera avec un
salaire bien inférieur
malgré les échelons qu'il prendra ça ne
compensera jamais le fait du calcul qui
est actuel et je voudrais dire que le
chef de l'état avait déclaré l'année
dernière qu'il n'y aurait pas de réforme
de retraite
tant qu'on n'aurait pas bâti une vraie
transformation du système de
rémunération de ces professions est
licite et les infirmières les
aides-soignants les enseignants et je
pense que aujourd'hui cette
transformation
elle n'a pas lieu et c'est ce qui fait
la difficulté et le manque de confiance
que nous avons dans cet article
et dans ces dispositions merci monsieur
à porter général
merci monsieur le président juste pour
pour répondre à notre collègue caroline
fiat ou essayer et j'y tiens parce
qu'effectivement dans vos propos il y a
beaucoup de vécu de sincérité et de
conviction à une une profession dont
nous connaissons toutes et tous ici mais
peut-être vous plus particulièrement
encore les difficultés en tout cas
d'expérience les difficultés
d'aujourd'hui auxquels nous devons
apporter des réponses sur les cas type
que vous citiez je me les noter sur une
feuille
je ne trouve pas les mêmes notamment
m'appuyant sur les cas type qui étaient
sur le site
retraites du gouvernement moi je les ai
encore je crois qu'ils aient disparu qui
donne une une niveau de pensions
supérieures à ce que ce que vous
annoncez mais peut-être que nous
pourrons en discuter voir comment vous
vous arrivez à ces niveaux là juste pour
dire que les cas type qui avait était
sur le qui avait été fait sur le site du
gouvernement entraîné une hausse
c'est mécanique niveau de pension
notamment par un double effet de prises
en compte effectivement des primes et un
deuxième effet lié fin de hausse liée à
l'indexation sur les revenus d'activité
des points qui entraîne qui entraîne une
hausse par ailleurs effectivement sur
les départs qui à terme ne seront plus à
57 ans ça connaissons qui seront
effectivement plus tard et qui impose
aujourd'hui une discussion qui a lieu
une concertation sur une réelle prise en
compte de la pénibilité et je pense le
plus large possible
par ailleurs également une meilleure un
meilleur accompagnement sur les fins de
carrière et l'ouverture de dispositifs
tels que le départ en retraite
progressif et également les possibilités
de congé pour reconversion qui doivent
être offerts ouvert assez à ces
professions voilà les quelques éléments
que je tenais en tout cas à apporter à
votre question nous allons donc voter
sur le 21 1629 et suivant chacun put
rugueux mais je me dise pas bonne et moi
j'en oublie pas de problème cependant
monsieur le président je vous remercie
j'en ai juste pour quelques secondes
c'est juste pour faire une remise
officielle au député boris vélo qui
était un petit peu perdues tout à
l'heure dans les références sans doute
avait mal donner des références mais je
les ai retrouvés sans problème pour lui
dire que évidemment il retrouvera dans
les travaux du cor je n'étais pas encore
le 17 mai 2010 est que la part des
primes dans la rémunération moyenne des
fonctionnaires civils d'état a eu
tendance à augmenter de 0 23 point par
an sur les 25 dernières années en
fonction de ce que je lui avais donné
donc je vais lui faire parvenir ce
document dans lequel il retrouvera les
informations
auxquels nous sommes basés pour l'étude
d'impact merci monsieur pognon merci
donc un rappel au règlement majeur
bayrac sens monsieur le président pour
savoir un peu on en est dans le cadre de
nos travaux six articles
nous sommes au sixième article il ya
soixante cinq articles
combien reste-t-il de l'amendement
combien reste-t-il d'amendements sur cet
article
au total il nous reste trempée 700
amendements
combien de sous-amendements ont été
porté à votre connaissance et est ce que
la proposition de loi que nous allons
examiner dans quelques moments va encore
retarder nos travaux je voudrais savoir
un peu comment vont s'organiser nos
travaux à l'accueillir
alors
alors on va donner la priorité aux
rappels rigan monsieur dharréville
chevalot s'était pas vraiment une
attaque personnelle je crois pas quand
même c'était une réponse réponse
monsieur des révisions monsieur le
président je vous remercie d'abord je
voudrais je voudrais faire observer un
autre notre collègue qui vient
d'intervenir les stands sur yb et roth
que la proposition de loi que nous
allons examiner ne va pas retarder nos
travaux elle va les alimenter utilement
puisqu'elle porte sur le thème de notre
débat et qu'il s'agit d'un droit inscrit
dans le règlement et moi ou salés
premier ministre a dit moi j'applique la
constitution toute la convainc quelle
constitution toute la constitution moi
j'applique le règlement rien que le
règlement et tout le règlement voilà
monsieur le bien première remarque la
deuxième je voudrais savoir je voudrai
savoir si il a été porté à la
connaissance du président de l'assemblée
nationale que le bureau du sénat
s'étaient réunis avaient demandé un
report pour ce qui le concerne de
l'examen de ce texte après la fin de la
conférence de financement à l'unanimité
cette demande a été faite à ma
connaissance par le bureau du sénat je
devrais savoir peut-être si nous
pourrions pas faire de même ici à
l'assemblée nationale alors mes chers
collègues on va prendre les rappels
règlement monsieur vélo pourrait
s'exprimer
monsieur k des nymphes et je vous
rappelle que dans peu de temps on va
effectivement examiné magique à des
menaces monsieur le président je fais un
rappel au règlement sur la base de
l'article son et du déroulé de nos
débats j'étais en train de préparer nos
prochaines interventions
quand j'ai entendu ce rappel au
règlement une nouvelle indignation sur
la prétendue obstruction et du coup j'ai
regardé l'heure et j'ai vu qu'il était
passé 23 heures
la fameuse heure fatidique à partir de
laquelle effectivement se réveille
toutes sortes de personnes pour venir
faire effectivement les indignations
nécessaire pour bien finir la séance
sauf que ça fait trois jours que ça dure
vous devriez au moins changer l'horaire
une fois passé 23 heures ça démarre la
machine se met en route
et comme il faut continuer accréditer la
thèse d'un 49 3 eh bien on commence les
injonctions monsieur le président au
secours des tenons nous en sommes bons
clairement ça suffit réactualisé un peu
la stratégie coach legendre entre le
marquage en défense les attaques du
numéro 10 monsieur cazeneuve et à 23h le
démarrage des rappels au règlement sur
le thème de l'obstruction parlementaire
je vous suggère une petite
réactualisation de votre stratégie
merci merci
donc voilà monsieur vallot